[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
quatrième partie du match de championnat
du monde qui oppose Yann et pomyachi à
dinglieren Vlad Yann qui a toujours un
point d'avance
donc toujours un poème d'avance pour mes
pots je suppose que malheureusement
plutôt malheureusement
Ding va pas nous surprendre aujourd'hui
avec son premier coup non il va prendre
surprendre donc des quatre des quatre ou
C4 C4 le moins probable
mais pas de 4 c'est sûr de toute manière
ça va être loin de ouverture firmer
pas plus ou moins sur moins même sur
100% je veux dire mais donc ça veut dire
que Ding il va pas suivre la règle des
Championnats du Monde d'ouvrir une fois
des quatre une fois E4 pour voir un peu
ce que l'adversaire a préparé tu sais en
fait avant le match dans les tournois
d'exhibition on aurait dit un peu comme
tu veux il est très souvent d'employé E4
donc par exemple avec
grosse surprise pour moi parce que je
m'entendais plutôt à des quatre recoller
3 C4 non parce que ça la remise
en fait
voilà donc plutôt surprenant même si
Ding la fois mille fois dans sa vie il
le fait plutôt bien d'ailleurs
par contre c'est déjà
bizarrement au premier coup c'est déjà
une surprise en fait
parce que nepo est plutôt pour jouer E5
et avec les dés surget3 C6 ce que très
très la mode chez le joueur de leader et
donc voilà ici d'habitude pourquoi
est-ce qu'un jour collectif c'est très
facile d'expliquer en fait
si les blancs indisent que ils veulent
jouer l'angoisse ils doivent jouer par
exemple elle est après le 5 comme ça le
noir on forcer les bandes de mettre le
cogolais sur ces trois qui va être
touché par exemple par le fou sur bucate
enfant il y a d'autres de Théo
ok normalement ne peau doit jouer que
ceci c'est sûr je Troie de 5 d'ailleurs
j'aime pas trop le choix de Ding dans
tous les cas parce que on est pour
était pendant des années de longues
années il a été un très très bon joueur
de l'angoisse avec avec les blancs avec
le bras
avec les Noirs aussi il est rémuné des
milliers de derrière Liban donc si vous
voulez pour l'instant je suis pas
un grand fanat dans sa décision
A3 je pense que même s'il est employé
peut-être très rarement je pense que
c'est pas un joueur de 3
le problème avec toi en fait
le coup le plus populaire ici c'est fou
peut-être
par exemple dams 2
vous prend 3 maintenant ici
donc les Siciliens
il y a un autre coup aussi
avec l'idée de mettre le pion sur E4
après je trouve les H4 etc mais
franchement jouer en fait c'est normal
de traiter ça qui sont connues de jeunes
elle vient de jouer ok donc dans ce cas
là je veux pas trop parler de dessin
qu'après E3 parce que c'est possible
mais c'est juste un autre universel par
contre
OK dans ce cas là je prévois après fou
c'est trois il va bouffer avec le coeur
parce que il faut bien se souvenir de
détails et peut-être parce que ça n'a
pas été joué par les joueurs d'élite
depuis un bon moment en fait est-ce que
je peux prendre de des
non tu peux pas ok bon tu sais pourquoi
ou
4 le noir sont nettement
horrible dans ce cas là pour les blancs
tu sais pas les Noirs je pense que c'est
même pas un peu mieux pour le noir
tu sais des fois comment il répond à qui
non et quand tu dis pourquoi tu demandes
pourquoi il leur dit la peur dit alors
voilà donc et si je joue D5 par exemple
c'est possible ça ou pas du tout ah non
je pense se décoller de 5 ans le 5 non
ou pas
je pensais
à quoi
tellement dur de calculer le matin quand
même quoi que ça se continue en fait
et après
et ceux qui veulent tester ma mémoire
peuvent le faire avec la base de données
je pense pas que je me trompe
D6 bon il sait qu'il va jouer this is en
avance donc il joue de sieste tout de
suite avance ok peut-être pour un
peut-être parce qu'il sait quelque chose
ou peut-être un postuler
il est beaucoup mieux dans son match
dans cette ouverture regarde il joue
plus vite que nepo il joue tempo il est
confiant qu'est-ce que vous arrive là
maintenant il joue normalement oui comme
on joue d'ailleurs toute sa vie
les deux premières parties il était pas
dedans les deux premières parties et
demi il était pas dedans et là ça y est
il est normal
trop de pression trop de stress j'ai pas
quelqu'un
de la Chine
je sais pas mais il avait l'air beaucoup
plus de ranconférence de presse c'est
vue hier dans la partie juste dans son
match donc ça ça va être hyper
intéressant aujourd'hui en tout cas les
deux sont partis et c'est une époque
aujourd'hui qui qui fait un peu la valse
du ventre
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est exactement pareil qu'aux candidat
ouais c'est c'est il est coutumier du
fait Ding dernièrement
c'est toi qui m'as dit où j'ai lu ça où
il y a quelqu'un qui m'a écrit qu'en
fait il a dit que pendant la période
covid il s'était séparé de sa copine et
que c'était une des explications
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui m'a dit
ça c'est pas toi bah oui
pendant le covid elle sortait pas dans
son coin ouais mais peut-être que
c'était une rupture amoureuse difficile
c'est peut-être plus ça que le covid qui
lui a fait mal en fait
c'est dur de ne pas rompre avec ta
copine si toi tu viens en Chine et
l'élevé
non mais c'est non mais ok je vais pas
moi je suis plus demandé en chinois que
je connais bien il peut me fournir mais
ça ça peut être une explication de sa
baisse de niveau et qu'est-ce que peut
être explication pour ce que le foutu
hier au niveau du temps
peut-être que c'est sa copine qui l'a
quitté il y a 3 ans non mais peut-être
que ça a eu un impact psychologique fort
peut-être qu'il était très amoureux j'en
sais rien moi ok hier quand elle est
cité tous les coups qu'il connaissaient
jouer déjà avant pendant 50 minutes
alors il est réfléchit de
ce sexe relation avec sa copine ah mais
regarde nepo il s'est mis à mieux jouer
quand il a une relation avec signer Jana
[Musique]
non mais c'est vrai qu'ils a commencé à
mieux jouer Yann quand il est où le
temps
c'est vrai que le nom est très beau
magnifique d'ailleurs il est pas que je
pense il est je pense qu'il y a des il y
a des femmes
Serbes qui ont un tel nom c'est
magnifique non le nombre fantastique
tout à fait sans aucun doute en tout cas
ça lui ça lui a permis de se stabiliser
et il a commencé à mieux jouer après ça
ça quand même son importance non bien
sûr il est vrai que les dimensions
sont tuées ou comment
l'a appelé un peu la plus différemment
bien sûr je joue un très grand rôle chez
les joueurs de chèque et souvent donc on
ne comprend pas qui est-ce qui se passe
avec le mecan t'en apprend de l'info
inside et en fait il y a une séparation
ou une trouvaille ou je sais pas quoi
oui ou un triangle ce qui arrive souvent
aussi
plus souvent qu'un carré
l'abstinence sexuelle augmente les
performances j'en sais quelque chose il
joue très mal d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs
récemment j'ai fouillé sur les infos sur
Fisher j'ai appris pas mal de choses que
je connaissais pas en fait
si pas mal de sources comme quoi c'est
cher a été asexuel
sinon pas c'est ce que j'ai toujours
pensé parce que sinon ce que je loue
d'accord sinon
vrai ami Lombardie et son secondant
en fait
lorsqu'il est toujours dans quoi il a
complètement adoré le tournoi à Buenos
Aires
buenaser donc tout le monde s'attendait
qu'il va prétendre pour les premières
places il fait gorille et en fait c'est
parce que souvent lombardier le mec
sortait pas du lit
si tu vois ce que je veux dire non pas
non pas une seconde
et donc
je vous partage avec vous
les connaissances que j'ai appris
[Musique]
le tournoi il a dit ah non plus
c'est plus important alors que moi j'ai
arrêté les échecs
[Rires]
comme ça j'ai dit les échecs plus jamais
quoi
comme quoi tu vois ça se joue pas
grand-chose parfois
une carrière
mais tu sais c'est ce que c'était une de
mes théories qui était possible à on en
sait rien mais avec Ali resa c'est vrai
que tu es jeune tu arrives à Paris tu as
beaucoup d'argent
ça peut
[Musique]
donner l'envie d'un peu moins travailler
les échecs quoi et donc
à la chasse des filles et après tu vas
pas être ça
non mais j'en sais rien il faudrait
demander à lire les a directement ça
peut tourner l’état bien sûr ça peut
tourner
tu es riche tu es à Paris
et en plus tu es invité en France en
tant que représentant de Fashion
industrie en plus
tu connais Ronaldinho
il a bien régressé quand il est arrivé à
Paris et tout le monde sait c'est parce
qu'il sortait en boîte de nuit et les
filles les machins donc ça ça joue réel
ça peut réellement jouer énormément sur
une carrière
ah tiens d'ailleurs
l'un de Me pronostic n'a pas marché il
n'a pas choisi le poids avec je crois
avec ça lui permet de tenir la case
différents en fait je pensais de
mentionner ça mais en n'a pas eu assez
de temps bien sûr c'est un autre plan
juste moins populaire mais qui a assez
point fort et parce que le fou comme ça
contrôle toujours
les diaganales F1 A6 et justement permet
pas donc c'est pour ça pour un certain
moment permet pas les pousser de 5 dons
qui en a mentionné dans nos commentaires
je dois dire deux choses sur son choix
d'ailleurs premièrement son choix de
YouTube
deuxièmement je pense encore une fois
avec les points ensemble l'impact de
rapporte parce que rapporte adore de
tels chez le chien de pions juste
adorent et comme ça toute sa vie là
aussi je
sens
comment dire son nom
en tout cas la pollution elle va être
hyper intéressante est-ce que on peut
faire un plan complètement fou et faire
un truc avec Détroit tour géants et G4
rarement mais genre faire des trois
fouger 5 provoqua H6 repartir
et juste envoyer
de toi il faut que je sens que tu
provoques H6 parce que je peux jouer
après faut que je sens que le 7
et j'ai pas peur de foudre si je gère
parce que je mets le correction
des réactions
après deux trois très probablement
l'adversaire va jouer comme les 7 par
exemple d'ailleurs figurons-nous que
une fois les Blancs ont choisi le plan
avec fou E2 et pas je trouve il y a
beaucoup plus de raison pour les noirs
de transférer le Cavoli sur justice
parce que F4
si tu fais ça je peux te faire G3 H4 je
peux te faire G3 H4 H5 je pense que
c'est plutôt
en tout cas moi j'ai envie de te dire
que j'ai pas envie de Roca avec les
Blancs moi je ferai des trois en premier
fou quelque part et après je verrai mais
je retarderai le rock
moi d'ailleurs ça m'intéresse quel point
je vais choisir moi je pense que
j'aurais essayé enfin si demain un truc
à la Cortina
voilà c'est l'une des idées que j'aurais
pu considérer très sérieusement
je pense pas non tu penses pas je pense
pas je pense que le problème c'est que
en fait le truc est complètement tombé
de l'amour en fait et donc c'est
possible que en fait ici il y en a pas
de moitié vous savez mais les échecs
mais
tu peux pas avoir les fichiers sur tout
mais juste tu peux pas tu peux pas
disons que par exemple pour mes élèves
je préparer un fichier
une base enfin un fichier énorme CE4
pour le noir
j'ai pas
4h5 D4 il y avait bien sûr toutes les
Espagnols les Italiens écosseuse de tout
et puis à un moment donné le petit midi
Vlad et comment je joue après ekat et
ressemble que les saucisses que les
trois colis food
je veux pas ça dans mon fichier
pourtant c'est une ligne qui existe
mais il a fait cavalier H5 comment aller
à 5 c'est intéressant parce que
pourquoi est-ce que je parlais de roi
Swift que les T5 est pas cavalier
H5 c'est très logique mais le problème
c'est que tu es complètement sûr que
c'est la première ligne qu'ils ont
regardé
et donc tu dois être sûr alors que c'est
que toi donc tu te rappelles
ou ce que toi tu connais ici c'est pas
moins bien que ce que tes adversaires
t'ont préparé
le problème je suppose l'un de l'un des
problèmes F5
donc de cadre maintenant alors
je suis d'accord avec toi c'est juste
physiquement
mais c'est courageux quand même parce
que tu es presque c'est presque sûr que
oui les regarde ça il y a quelques
années
et Dingler avant le match est réputé
hier avant de partir donc
pas très catholique comme les décisions
mais bon maintenant donc les joueurs
vont comparer leur prépa
c'est bien d'être courageux comme ça je
trouve
non
le plus souvent non trop dangereux le
plus souvent test que ton adversaire a
préparé pas sur toi moi sur les autres
tu penses qu'il vaut mieux être pleutre
oui non après le simple pas simple
est-ce qu'il veut est-ce qu'il veut
dribbler simple très clair et
c'est bien ça d'ailleurs
un plâtre illuminer à contrario du
pleutre pénombre et
[Rires]
un intercours qu'il faut
mentionner ici ce bien sûr dans le 6
parce que parce que parce que
je pense que
et qu'est-ce qui se passe alors
[Musique]
je sais pas en fait mon fou il est hyper
mal placé vous allez donc j'ai trois
j'ai pas trop d'envies
c'est pour ça que je joue non je préfère
te donner ce pion OK
je passe
je sais pas
mais ok moi j'ai pas peur dedans je dors
tout simplement parce que je suppose que
ça a l'air trop dangereux ouais genre
même grand rock là oui oui parce que je
pense
donc plutôt pas d'arme jeu 2 sur 5 je
voyage 4
donc peut-être
souvent
il a joué il a joué qui avait des F4
direct
comme G3 ici
non non
[Musique]
peut-être non de toute manière j'aime
pas et je vois mon patron
en fait
juste
[Musique]
un peu trop c'est un peu trop ok
juste petit
c'est pas la peine de chercher
d'inventer les bicyclettes un truc
simple je vais pas à Tourcoing je pense
que les banques
H5 tour H4
et pourquoi faire pour gagner un pion
quoi
le truc c'est que
je vais jamais réagir tu vois
je veux faire bien sûr d'amopsis tu
joues à 5 je ferai tout oui je viens
quoi j'insiste oui mais t'as pas de mes
notes
ok
je veux juste
c'est juste pour qu'on soit très clair
je veux juste Ken en fait
[Rires]
parce que je crois que tu as pas bien
compris en fait
[Rires]
cette phrase là
bon
je pense que ce bouton
[Musique]
tu dois pas être bien alors en fait
non mais bon c'est on rigole enfin on
s'en fout quoi mais c'est juste que il y
a du rapport un peu dans ce hache quoi
trop quand même c'est un peu rapporté
comme plan un tel que rapporte
là tu as raison mais c'est juste que
c'est juste que je pense que après petit
rock tout bêtement les bandes sont mis
au juste parce que je peux je préfère
les structure de bois parce que je
comprends que en fait avec EF
les Noirs ont perdu leur souplesse oui
c'est plus souple en fait tandis que
mais mais qui a le centre quoi
qui a le centre moi c'est bien moi quand
même mais c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
peur pour mon roi hein c'est pour ça que
j'ai pas peur pour mon roi et que je
veux insister sur ton pion
en fait c'est parce que j'ai le centre
attends vas-y je vais je vais checker
sur ceci pour voir qui a raison
ils l'ont pas encore la nouvelle partie
Vlad comprend mieux les échecs c'est
terrible bah j'espère il a été top 20
mondial quand même évidemment qui
comprend mieux mais bon on rajoute un
peu de piquant avec nos
conversations il a fait petit
non
de suite il est vrai c'est bien pratique
parce que comme ça tu échanges enfants
tu repris de la paire de fou moi je
pense que c'est trop m'embrasse
je pense que c'est juste moins bien
est-ce qu'il y a encore des parties dans
la base d'ailleurs après sûr que non
sûr que non et c'était à chaque le côté
horrible
non et c'est ta partie d'ailleurs c'est
qui qui a joué à H4 c'était vraiment H4
la théorie
ici quelqu'un ne veut pas oui mais moi
j'appelle ça théorie
donc petit rock nouveauté
je vais voir qui a joué ça
ils disent que ces rapports en fait
vraiment
[Rires]
rapporte
que moi
OK
[Rires]
et l'ordinateur préfère quoi
l'ordinateur est pas assez puissant tu
peux pas le mettre dans la pleine
puissance pendant qu'on stream en fait
donc je peux pas dire mais peut-être que
quelqu'un pourra nous dire
en fait
je pense que les Noirs aurait pu avoir
les positions acceptables
si les Noirs réalisent ça va mais sa
mentionnerait et
c'est très agréable de jouer avec les
bonsoir
ils ont peut-être analysé cette position
côté népo est-ce qu'il a eu
comment
jouer j'ai pas en plus n'oublie pas
rapporte ma page jouer à cette partie
contre quelqu'un fort
que j'attends son nom là donc
je peux te dire qu'il est pas terrible
non c'est juste comme d'habitude une
fois poisson
tout de suite il montre sa mauvaise
compréhension parce que il comprend pas
trop les échecs parlant du numéro 2 quoi
parlons
donc je pense que ce juste nous une
autre fois elle monte son défaut et donc
maintenant il dit tout faire bien il va
souffrir
et pas pour intervenir mais il faut
souffrir pour ne pas
souffrir quoi il va souffrir pour ne pas
souffrir
[Rires]
en fait je peux vous assurer je pensais
à turban turbo 5 non mais arrête tu dis
pas H4 H5 et tu fais tomber en tomber 5
non mais c'est trop mais pas avec les
deux tours je sens avec les deux juste
je crois plutôt que un moment donné
pour le chat quoi c'est pas possible
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça tout d'un
coup de tomber un tour
merci je m'entendais à ce genre de
commentaires après le
sophisme que je balançais tout à l'heure
je m'attendais à ça merci de tout mon
coeur
bah du coup c'est tout refait un fou D3
non si tu me dis que c'est pas tout
refait un fou des trois le plan j'arrête
j'arrête le stream en fait
en attendant en attendant les questions
éternelles
turban 6 au milieu ou pas mais
c'est une question éternelle aux échecs
en fait il y a plusieurs questions
éternel aux échecs comme par exemple à
autour FDA oui ici c'est clair que ce
taux oui il a sauvé le streamer
et une autre question quand vous avez
une colonne semée ouverte ouais par
exemple mettre ou ne pas mettre
les coutures automatique ou pas c'est
une question éternelle quoi que après
tout bon il est pas obligé de faire
baisser il peut offrir
le plus souvent non mais moi je préfère
ne pas faire pour le moment parce que je
préfère attendre que le fou bouge
histoire d'être sûr qu'il fasse quelque
chose parce que là si tu fais tout
rabais un qui sait peut-être il commence
par G5 j'en sais rien j'ai une connerie
hein
tu lui laisses l'option quand même
d'ignorer de faire plus tard
alors que s'il avait bougé le fou j'ai
une bêtise ici tomber un là tu sais que
tu provoques à
100%. tu vois ma logique
d'un point de vue pratique j'aurais
plutôt fait Tour Eiffel aussi d'abord
ok je veux pas mentir et je veux je veux
pas me faire passer pour audio bien sûr
j'aurais fait
ok normalement entre une ou deux minutes
de toute façon
bien en avance ce que je veux faire
non mais là tu es quand même tu as quand
même un bel avantage avec les Blancs la
sortie de l'ouverture non pour l'instant
pour l'instant je dois dire au niveau du
boulot avec les Blancs
bravo rapport tout le monde respecte
pour mon pour le collègue
il fait son bien
fantastique pour l'instant il montre que
il vaut comment dire il voulait une que
les dépayés même si c'était vraiment
beaucoup parce que c'est excellent ce
qu'il faut
ça a été peut-être beaucoup peut-être
pas mais qui a payé du coup
c'est comme ça que ça marche en Russie
je pense que en Chine plus rien mais
est-ce que c'est de l'humeur des Chinois
de payer des gens extérieurs comme ça
d'habitude il le faisait pas non il
restait un peu en justement
nouveauté fantastique parce que c'est
une deuxième idée par Monsieur rapporte
qui est en train de ramener que quand
même des résultats quoi et je suppose
que le plus probablement
ils ont préparé de tel trucs pour cette
partie blanche voire plus
pourquoi ils vont en fait changer et
c'est exactement ce qu'il faut faire
contre l'héroscope la guerre à
symétrique les bons ouais donc pour que
à un moment donné avant les parties avec
le noir l'équipe russe peut juste aller
je pas à Disneyland ou je sais pas quoi
parce que en fait rien à de toute
manière en principe de deviner ce qui va
arriver sur le chien mais ils doivent
quand même travailler parce que sinon on
n'est pas content voilà moi j'étais dans
cette situation là parce que 2014
à partir d'un moment donné ni eux
pouvaient jamais deviner ce que on va
ni nous non plus
comme tu dis comme vous dites avec
Baptiste
moi j'ai toujours toi
mais des pièces sur des cases juste
[Musique]
et ça marche
bah qui lui arrive juste qu'il joue en
coup parce que la souris est pas loin
aux échecs les plus important c'est de
ne pas mettre les pièces sur les cases
les plus faibles c'est
les cases que peut-être pas une seule
pièce de toi avoir même toucher un
moment donné mais ça va jouer quand même
bah qu'il a une autre stratégie aussi
c'est qu'il attaque de loin parce qu'il
dit que c'est dur de voir les coups
genre imagine tu as un fou en G2 ok une
tour en 8 ok c'est loin
ça peut tomber
du coup il joue de loin aussi donc faut
de trois bientôt E5 c'est loin c'est
loin c'est loin mais du coup c'est dur à
voir donc c'est un gros piège en fait
qu'il est en train de tendre
voilà donc non messieurs
mais pour
le regroupement je sens que le site que
les justices vous allez jamais réussir
dans cette partie
est-ce qu'il est un peu en train de
rougir n'est pas
bien sûr il est en rejet de comment
s'appelle
[Musique]
à quel point on comprend pas bien les
échecs
d'ailleurs
avant pendant les trois premières
parties il a joué Pinard assez
mal et tout oui aujourd'hui une fois il
a pour la deuxième fois il a rencontré
un point ok il était pas trop près là
tout de suite sans réfléchir bien comme
à l'époque complètement comme à l'époque
complètement à l'époque hystérique pas
bien pas de compréhension hystérique
pour faire croire que tu sais ah ouais
de même que Macron
d'ailleurs est-ce que tu penses que
Makoun est dans l'équipe de dingue
[Rires]
je pense son prénom c'est ma et son nom
c'est cool ou inversement bah c'est
toujours de dire
par exemple ceux qui
savent pas
amandes c'est pas son nom de famille
son nom de famille s'est Vichy
son prénom tu veux dire son prénom ah
non c'est son prénom bah oui mais
pourquoi
et comme ça mille fois avec les Indiens
en fait mille fois en fait
comment
mais il le prend pas mal que tout le
monde l'appelle amende ah ok il est
tellement habitué depuis l'âge de j'ai
pas 12 ans qui est tant pis mais sinon
il doit être vexé non pas pourquoi pas
je m'en fous tu m'appelles voilà bon
merci
j'ai aucun problème
c'est quand même particulier tu vois ça
je savais pas du tout et du coup
pragamanda là c'est
le prénom
en fait je sais pas pourquoi non
quelqu'un m'a expliqué mais j'ai oublié
déjà vous croyez-moi je ne vends pas les
autres soirs je sais pas c'est fort pour
inventer
je suis fort pour expliquer les mal que
compréhension
stratégique de
fois il est sorti de ses positions
que je joue souvent oui là tout de suite
ça part un coup stratégiquement
pour bien comprendre
où là
bon c'est complexe en gros
mais ils te disent vite c'est son prénom
OK et du coup c'est son touche son nom
ou peut-être que ça me fait extrêmement
plaisir
bougera-t-il c'est bon non c'est bon
c'est vrai je pense qu'il y a une ville
good rate possible mais en tout cas le
Santo je bougera team mais très très
bien
je te raconter l'histoire comme ça
shakirane a joué pour qu'un échec
ok à l'époque l'un des meilleurs joueurs
indiens
c'est vraiment de jouer pour canne chic
et donc il est assis avec nous pendant
les dîner pendant
les déjeuner et à chaque fois elle boit
rien vous dites pourquoi est-ce que tu
bois pas
qu'est-ce que tu veux un café non
de l'eau
pétillant pétillante non le jour non il
y avait une seule poisson pour lequel il
était chaud
mais c'est impossible de deviner quoi
le reste il a jamais accepté mais les
Indiens ils ont pas un truc avec les
ouais non je sais pas avec les vaches
les machins
bon les vaches
pas du tout au courant de tout ça
donc il pouvait que ça c'est pas que ça
c'est bizarre
tu m'as étonné là j'aurais jamais pu
deviner du lait moi non plus
qu'est-ce que je peux dire pas pratique
le couple peut pas être trop mauvais le
coup peut pas être trop bien non plus
parce que il
aide pas au noir de résoudre ni un
problème ni l'autre juste en cours pour
passer quoi alors
après c'est le genre de coup que tu dois
regarder mais
décès
dames
c'est un peu ok ça peut être très fort
non mais ça peut être hyper
Fortin pour préparer j'imagine pour
adverbe possible
pour moi ce serait pas être clair
pourquoi est-ce que je mets le tour ici
[Musique]
il est parti pour un auteur toi en fait
il a compris ce que il a prévu marcher
en gros il veut quoi fou de cette
recette aura 8 je sens que attendre
quelque chose dans ce genre
normal mais je suis pas sûr que lui
autant faut que je cadre donc il va
jouer au foot alors je pense le point en
général du mec cette recette si vous
voulez mais pour n'a jamais été un génie
oui bien sûr mais pour étant génie de
décision pratique souvent
ils ont ils puent merder à la vitesse
cosmique puis il s'est mis réfléchir
j'ai pas dit 15 minutes 10 15 minutes et
puis après donc il crée juste une
position comme quoi pretty quoi fait le
problème que tu as c'est quand tu mets
ta tour en 7 tu te prends ça en force
ah bon ça je veux pas considéré bien
j'essaye juste de comprendre en fait ça
ça tu te le prends en force ok ça ça
fait non mais en général en général le
réflexe de
toute manière est bon d'accord
tu fais ça et tu sais pas ce que les
Noirs font en fait oui oui oui oui oui
en fait comment dire
les Noirs violent
joue fou de toi voilà donc j'ai pas bien
tourné les phrases
et c'est comme quoi l'harmonie totale et
puis donc juste un très bon avantage
à 10 respect total pour que les quatre
de ne pas
c'est pas mal
candidat pour le titre que les gens que
[Musique]
Médine il va probablement partir pour ça
en fait c'est hyper logique
ok vous jouez à un coup de tour comme
tout radin puis H3 fou D3
pas moi le bon choix moi le plus je
réfléchis le plus j'aime le choix de un
voyage parce que comme ça tu définis pas
encore les positions de Toto
3 2 tours tu vois la matière sur un d'un
coup tu veux faire ça en fait
après tu fais ça tu fais dame de dos et
peut-être tu vois un moment donné tu
veux menacer ton E5 et pour viser le
mauvais signe pour nez pas mais c'est
sûrement ce que tu dois jouer là mais
l'ordi en fait il propose j'ai cinq H5
G4 déjà
par contre déjà
c'est ce que je voulais dire
évidemment non mais évidemment qu'il va
le faire et digne clossen en fait il va
faire H5 et puis tu vas faire peut-être
tour 2 il va faire G5 tu vas faire
tourner un il veut G4 c'est pour montrer
tu vas faire ça d'ailleurs
je dois vous dire que
c'est un joueur de cet arbre avec G3
d'accord pour son roi non si c'est le
cas comme c'est le cas
c'est forcément un bon joueur de
dire que de 3 donc je sens que tout ça
il va pas se faire dans cette partie
croyez-moi
c'est si quelqu'un joue les étapes aux
jeux 3 depuis 30 ans
il voit trouver moyen de d'éviter cette
avalanche depuis
d'une manière à l'autre mais de toute
manière une chose je dois vous dire sur
que tout Ader
mais du coup je comprends pourquoi
l'ordinateur veut
leur H3 fou de cette parce que une fois
le Fou est sûr de cette tu peux faire
tout
pour des raisons
qui partent pour H5
mais là je veux vous
ce simple après tout
en question admettons que je fasse trois
pourquoi pas je sens
que ceci c'est si grave mais ok je
oui je bouge
non c'est peut-être pas si grave
ça va pas quoi
c'est pour ça qu'il réfléchit peut-être
que tu veux
est-ce que fout des trois directs faut
que j'ai 4 c'est si grave
tu peux me passer ça laisse trop de
liberté au noir qui bouge pas sinon
n'engage je crois fou des sept tourner
oui et là je dois même moi pendant les
parties j'ai rien compris que je menace
donc disons que tu auras des 8
H2 non ça c'est toujours une possibilité
mais même mais c'est trop gridi
ok disons toujours ok
si tu as joué tu rappelles tu veux jouer
ce soir
bon normalement
[Musique]
c'est pas fait c'est sûr tu sais que tu
es mieux mais c'est pas facile à non il
faut bien sûr oui il faut être précis
qui proposait de faire H3 fou D7 fous
des trois
géant mais
j'ai trois moment donné
mais je sais pas c'est un message à
longtemps donc je sais pas si s'il
réagissait par rapport à quelque chose
non
ça tu peux pas faire
tu peux pas empêcher alors
bon moi à vrai dire
je pense pas qu'il y a trop d'options
non plus
parce que tu veux pas mettre ton fou sur
essence
il fait j'ai 5
et genre là on fait tour B1 tiens d'ordi
OK et c'est quoi les deux
possible dans ce cas-là
ouais après tourbe tu as toutes les
raisons de considérer ce sang
je sens que de 5 d'amour
tu pousses mais peut-être tu m'aides
F5 dans F5 essayer de pénétrer un peu et
notons quand même
je pense les tensions favorable parce
que les Blancs attaquent les Noirs
défendent un bon exemple c'est qu'on
pourra on aurait pu dans certaines
variantes
en fait on n'a pas plus de gaz les noirs
[Musique]
des décalages on décale en premier les
noirs peuvent pas décaler il a joué
fout des trois ok connerie
c'est incroyable en train de filer ce
fouet sur 6 sur ça sur 6 sur ça
une autre idée quoi
vas-y vise le trou comme Tiger Wood quoi
une seule idée qui existe pour les Noirs
je me permets de te rappeler que c'était
rapporte qui jouait il est déjà tard
il aurait déjà envoyé en fait
il est possible de murder il va faire
quoi
j'ai 4
il a déjà pourri toute sa prépa en un
coup quoi
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour que tu meurs pas
il va faire quoi cavaler des deux
est-ce que E5 ça peut marcher
c'est terrible
par contre
c'est le niveau
du point 1500
[Rires]
[Musique]
le problème est là certes
tu veux dire qu'il est dans les tuyaux
en ce
moment-là
plus de problème plus jamais de problème
ah c'est trop et ce serait beau qu'il
revienne avec une carapace de tortue
quoi
il la pose sur la table
[Rires]
le plombier digne quoi
il revient avec une casquette rouge
[Musique]
[Rires]
avec un D dessus quoi
bonjour il y a un problème
non mais c'est trop ok vas-y vas-y
réfléchis 10 minutes
non reviens dans 10 minutes fini de
réparer les chiottes d'accord
[Rires]
tu sais les miennes sont aussi cassées
il est parti
[Musique]
quand même regarde il est de nouveau là
quoi
non mais c'est quelque chose quoi
[Rires]
[Musique]
après ça reste quand même agréable pour
les blancs même si l'ordi
pas si clair
bon
déjà par exemple il peut offrir
maintenant un tour à de 8 et après faut
ce weekend
après tout boire ici sous turbo ça y est
le fou le fouet sur la bonne case c'est
les murs
[Rires]
[Musique]
désolé
tu vas réparer
un petit break
c'est trop c'est trop le cavalier des
deux
c'est terrible ça me fait penser à la
scène le rire de Vlad il me fait penser
à la scène dans les affranchis
marrant marrant marrant comment quand
tout le monde se marre ça me fait penser
à ça
l'erreur de Vlad il me fait penser au
rire de
elliotta sur dans cette scène
exactement le même rire que reliotta
dans cette scène
genre copier coller
cavalière
marron marrant marrant comment alors la
bonne nouvelle c'est que ces deux
nouveaux plus 07 non mais c'est trop
cavalier à 5 blagues
cavalière 5 c'est vraiment à côté je
crois bon moi j'ai regardé alors comme
ça mais ça paraît pas du tout le plan le
cavalier est tellement mal placé en plus
ça se met dans le cavalier des deux qui
protège ses quatre
ah c'est exceptionnel qu'elle est à 5
ah ouais ça a pas l'air ça a pas l'air
terrible en fait je vois les lignes de
l'ordi ça a pas l'air top c'est vraiment
un côté cavalier à 5 c'est sur fin juste
ça se sent et ça se voit en fait le
cavalier est hyper mal placé il touche
rien
en fait il est il est fermé en fait
c'est il est à côté du jeu
bah d'ailleurs l'ordi un 6 pour ces cinq
maintenant dc-e5 pour jouer D5 et le
damashi c'est des 5 et maintenant c'est
très trouvable le cavalier est
complètement hors-jeu ah ouais non
cavalier à 5 c'est vraiment mal joué et
c'est même pas la ligne numéro 1
la ligne numéro 1 c'est damacat pour
toucher B6 et F3 le fou peut plus allant
des 7
Vlad
je crois qu'il est parti
et du coup les pièces noires se
retrouvent mal placées
pas à cavalier à 5 tu auras des 8
c'était évidemment le coupe données Vlad
c'était en fait le coup numéro 2 de
l'ordi mais qui donnait égalité et il
avait raison sur H3 c'était fou C8
ça a l'air assez mal joué mais bon après
il doit y avoir des raisons nous on
rigole parce que il faut bien meublé que
c'est long mais si les joueurs font ces
erreurs là c'est c'est parce que c'est
compliqué
donc cavalier à ça ouais d'accord il
veut dans ma carte leur dit ouais c'est
mais dans ma carte c'est dur j'aurais
dit j'aurais dit que c'était dur et sur
H3 genre un coup plus logique on va dire
ok c'est Fouache 5 déjà seul coup ouais
ça va pas du tout pour les noirs
parce que foodé 7 maintenant cavalier F3
et cavalier C6 et c'est les blancs qui
ont gagné un tempo ou pas
non retombe dans ce qu'on avait vu on
retombe avec un temps de plus
ce qu'il a fait fouger 4 des 7
oui il a perdu un tempo avec les Noirs
il fait ça
puisqu'il a joué deux trois quatre coups
et nous on a fait 1 2 3 donc c'est la
même avec un temps de plus
donc H3 Fouday 7 cavalier F3 mais oui
les cavaliers c'est 6 c'est logique en
fait le cavalier il est hyper mal parce
que maintenant menace 5 donc cavalier
c'est si c'est forcé donc ça veut dire
que sur H3 c'est foish5 forcée mais le
fois H5 il est pas très bien placé ici
bon il veut fouger 6 et contrer la
diagonale mais maintenant elle sait 5
effort dce-5 damage 6 D5 ouais ça a
quand même une belle tête ça pour les
blancs
mais moins fort que damacap probablement
ouais parce que dans ma carte ça touche
aussi dans ces variantes là le pion F4
peut-être
mais en tout cas ça rend pas confiance
ce cavalier sur A5
pour les Noirs un cavalier mvl mais
cavalier mal placé éloigné du jeu très
éloigné du jeu
je comprends pas pourquoi il a mis là en
fait je comprends pas ce qui touche
comme je disais il touche ses quatre
mais ces quatre est blindé par les
Blancs donc damaka on va essayer d'un
peu regarder ce que dit leur dit bon
cavalier 6 on va même pas regarder parce
que sinon c'est illogique ce que vient
de faire un époque donc c'est B6 à 100%.
maintenant F3 donc qui est un peu dans
l'idée de cavalier des deux
on va se dire fou H5 pour le moment même
s'il faut aussi c'est une option il veut
cavalier B3 mon cavalier B7 est bizarre
parce que le cavalier repart un peu dans
n'importe quoi et ca va les prendre B3
AB bon et là je pense qu'on comprend
tous de par la structure
que c'est nettement mieux pour les
blancs regardez juste fin ça fait un
genre de truc central hyper puissant et
on veut ici dame C6 B4 B5 par exemple
fixer à 7 allez le gagner en force donc
invalid B3 on pourrait pas échanger
faudrait peut-être repartir vers B7 mais
ouais bon c'est c'est la partie pas
terminée mais on voit qu'on est
complètement à l'envers là avec avec les
noirs on va pas regarder plus loin
donc cavalier à 5 damac 4 B6 F3 donc il
faut faire fou E6
cavalier B3 de toute façon on doit jouer
cavalier prend AB et ici qu'est ce que
fait l'ordi ouais non c'est trop ok ici
l'ordi dit dame D8 mais et ça c'est net
avantage blanc il y a Maxime je parle
sous le contrôle de Maxime dans le chat
ça pour moi c'est net avantage blanc
je sais pas si on va la gagner ou pas
mais c'est une position de rêve pour moi
j'attends le contrôle Maximus
qu'évidemment
on n'a pas des champions du monde pour
rien dans ce chat
mais pour moi j'aurai l'impression que
c'est déjà plus un plus ok entre plus
0,89 et un 50
l'ordi donne que plus 0,7 mais ça me
paraît
ça me paraît très mal payé
est-ce que l'idée c'est de jouer c'est 5
ça me paraît impossible de toute façon
tu as pas le temps en fait sur bamaka tu
as juste pas le temps mais en soi même
si je joue un truc pépère comme ça
ouais tu veux peut-être c'est ça mais
personne va te le donner en fait
mais quand bien même c'est 5 il faudrait
même regarder E5 et des seins enfin non
mais je sais pas ça me paraît trop
bizarre
parce qu'en fait quand tu fais C5 même
admettons que fasse tourbé un c'est ça
il faut même regarder E5 d'ailleurs dès
cavaliers E4
ok ça me fait 5 je sais pas je vois pas
quand tu le fais marcher
non cavalier à 5 je pense que le coup
est vraiment catastrophique enfin c'est
un couple j'aurais même pas envisagé
personnellement je suis nettement moins
fort que mais ouais je comprends pas le
coup en réalité
et cavalier B3 direct est-ce que c'est
une option
qui avait les prend B3 AB bon peut-être
en ayant introduit F3 quand même
bon on va pas faire fou aussi parce que
ça forcerait mais genre est-ce que ça
avec le pion en B7 c'est moins clair
parce que tu peux te faire fixer
bon dans ma carte c'est pas si simple
quand même il faut dire comme toujours
ça peut pas ces joueurs peuvent pas
jouer des coups aussi facilement
réfutables mais je trouve que le coup a
une tête bizarre quoi
je trouve que la tête du coup est
étrange
et c'est ça tout de suite pour les
blancs avec e5d c'est aussi jouable pour
jouer contre le cavalier à 5 longs c'est
pour ça il y a deux options
intéressantes et on peut évidemment
introduire H3 ou F3
ouais
c'est 5 mais je vois pas que dans quel
monde fait comme je disais en fait même
c'est 5 déjà 4 c'est un danger et je
vois pas dans quel monde ça passe en
fait
mais c'est peut-être ce que disait
Maxime il s'est dit que il pouvait pas
rester bloqué
comme ça et donc
il réfléchit
Manding mais et du coup il a voulu se
libérer entre guillemets
je pense ça vient du fait que nepo a
évalué la position comme très difficile
on va voir j'entends juste là qui est en
train de revenir mais la position
semble de nouveau vraiment à l'avantage
de Ding on va voir sa réaction
tu vas être étonné par le coup de Yann
il a fait cavalier à 5 à tempo
ici je sais pas moi ça me paraît très
bizarre visuellement cavalier à 5 je
comprends pas pourquoi en fait
parce que c'est en cours typique pour
les newsou quand tu prends sur ces trois
avec le pion non mais ça je sais mais je
veux dire là en fait il a amené le
cavalier en D2 le pion C4 est blindé
qu'est-ce que tu fais avec ton cavalier
ici en fait
peut-être
dans quoi que non c'est ça une façon au
pire déjà tu as déjà E5 puis on prend
cavalier 4G non je viens de dire une
connerie non
en anglais aussi mais juste non ok il
veut
quand même en cours en avance qu'il va
faire parce que au prochain coup il va
faire baisser
je te montre le la réplique de l'ordi
vas-y bon tu peux commencer par F3 ou
pas questionnable mais bon on va
commencer comme ça bon il fait F3 comme
ça il y a pas de foudre et le fou sur 5
je peux pas donc
oui quand tu dois prendre le bruit et AB
ok mais ça c'est visible donc c'est et
après dame saucisse ça c'est ce que je
disais c'est nette avantage non enfin là
il donne que 06 mais moi j'aurais pensé
que c'est déjà au moins 09
bah non mais c'est dégueulasse ça
de toute manière d'habitude que vous
voulez tu veux pas permettre
il prend prend et à 5
donc juste si tu réussis à comprendre ça
bah c'est pas si facile mais du coup tu
comprends que tu vois
parce que tu as envie ça c'est normal
comme coup pour pas laisser de F3 ou
noir il bouge le fou et cavalier B3 et
ok enfin tant qu'elle c'est un énorme
avantage
ok une autre question et moi je non tu
comprends pas que il a pas compris OK
d'accord
donc dessert
mais qu'est-ce qui comprennent au final
qui a dit il y a une éternité il y a
très longtemps branchten a dit que les
joueurs d'élite sont le plus souvent les
joueurs de lutte comme
c'est les positions que ils connaissent
sinon très souvent ça change
toute manière c'était dur mais c'est
face et frustrant de voir un match du
championnat du monde depuis la fin de la
prépa ici on va dire ok c'est une faute
de fautes trois fautes déjà bon c'est ça
qu'on peut pas dire que c'est une faute
c'est intéressant aussi mais je veux
dire que d'arnaque kb3 quand tu le vois
tu as envie de le faire enfin si tu le
vois
tu vois que tu peux jouer dans ma cadre
au lieu de 60
c'est facile si tu comprends pas que
Google
avec les dettes de 5 c'est
c'est pas un bon avantage aussi non à
cause de ces cinq
peut-être ça ce qu'il est préparé parce
que optiquement après c'est quand même
plus 0,7 tour E1 c'est très facile de
jouer parce que ça coule comme ça quoi
et je
tiens à ma figurer que que je sens que
si ça arrive un peu arrêter
en fait dans la 4 mais
pas dur du tout non mais ça ça devait
être pour pas qu'il trouve ça devait
être dur parce que cette position là tu
as quand même envie
d'ailleurs moi j'avais dit cavaliers B3
parce que c'est naturel
l'ordi préfère E5 moi je refuse
bah oui donc c'était pas dur puisque moi
j'ai trouvé le coup pas d'ordi et
j'avais pas regardé en fait j'avais
juste dit ok qui avait trois tropiques
mais c'est bizarre quand même
le match de candidate de ne pas digne de
l'être
bon maintenant
ça c'était l'autre truc intéressant
quand même parce que il veut damage 6 D5
ok ça a l'air quand même pas mal
qu'il est pas joué l'autre truc parce
que ça donne envie aussi en fait et
après de 5 d'ailleurs
aussi c'est pour ça qu'il a raté bon je
peux comprendre je peux comprendre je
suis d'accord avec toi Maxime pas
toujours cette fois-ci oui je suis
d'accord ouais en fait ça ça donne
tellement envie aussi
mais là c'est juste il devait choisir
entre deux
il a pas forcément choisi le meilleur
ça arrive
on comprend
à chaque fois donc ça y est recommence
de c'est grimace
pas trop je veux dire
ça aussi pour les blancs mais juste un
pion
matérielle
mais le cavalier à 5 est vraiment dégueu
de toute manière
quand on a analysé la position après
dans etc à chaque fois on a parlé que
les bandes veulent viser les pousser au
centre bien sûr que vous allez à 100 que
si bizarre que ça parce que ça faiblit
le contrôle sur cette case non mais je
dirais qu'elle va aller à 5 c'était
vraiment étonnant comme coup mais je
pense que c'est expliqué par le fait
qu'il pensait qu'après tour D8 fossés 8
il serait bloqué
et qui devait s'activer
mais
dans son livre
en français comment les échecs imitent
la vie c'est exactement les motifs je
pense moi c'est tout à fait et il a
expliqué que dans les positions
inférieures
très souvent tu as pas le droit de jouer
trop actif parce que ce jour tu as ta
position elle tient pas l'activité
énergétique au niveau de l'énergie et il
s'écroule
j'ai essayé d'expliquer ça par mes mots
ça se vérifie par la pratique d'ailleurs
donc malgré un gros envie bien sûr de
s'activer parce que
quand les positions n'est pas si il veut
pas donc d'un autre côté pendant très
longtemps les gens défendu de manière
très passive ont perdu plein de parties
battements
sans prendre leur chance pratique
oui mais ce que tu viens de dire c'est
évident ce que je viens de dire c'est
moi ma vie dedans
mais par contre toi
avec les défauts ce 8 on ne peut pas
dire que les noirs sont complètement
bloqués bloqués bloqué parce que le noir
solidifie leur position mais il veut
après je sens que donc il y a de moyenne
quand même de se réactiver
et n'oublions pas l'idée même ce que on
a dit de cavalier F4F c'est de commencer
à damocisse je sens qu'à chaque c'est
l'idée même du truc donc il aurait donc
en gros
il se compteur dit lui-même
comme si souvent après c'est dur
[Musique]
après c'est dur quand tu joues c'est
toujours dur
bon après là alors 10 c'est ce qu'on
nous a dit dans le chat avec les ordis
puissants
c'est dommage quand même qu'il ait pas
eu le dame à 4 kb3 parce que ça
paraissait en plus tellement facile à
jouer c'était zéro risque je pense que
moi même si il le refait au plus tard et
les retrouver les moyens de
on est d'accord que c'était une position
facile à jouer l'autre c'était égalité
matérielle avantage long terme zéro
risque mais on se demande si il y en a
des positions facile à jouer pour
[Musique]
le mec la cascade le plombier
il y en a mais dans les tuyaux
[Rires]
bon maintenant c'est quoi la réaction
humaine alors de recette ou glucides
plutôt possible parce que de toute
manière
moi je trouve ça normal
je sais pas je sais pas 100% sur en fait
parce que pour l'instant tu n'as pas
besoin en fait
je sais pas qu'est-ce que tu peux faire
au lieu de ça mais tu peux t'en as pas
besoin
on pose une question
facile ici tour de 8 alors c'est 4
maintenant
pas mal pas mal je dois dire parce que
c'est l'idée c'est pas mal c'est c'est
le setup parfait on aurait dit parce que
d'un côté c'est actif de l'autre côté
c'est prophète
à 4 tu aurais 8 dames C3 au moins tu en
as 4 c'est trop dip quoi parce que tu
vois pas de raison de jouer à 4h
mais la tour va nulle part plus tard
parce que E3 je crois H3 tout est
contrôler mais c'est juste pour voir un
peu une ligne quoi
pour voir ce que ça donne
là maintenant sur des six puis on prend
tu protèges
et tes keblo en fait
tu vas te rendre quand même G5 dans la
tronche comme c'est un tel structure
avec un défi matériel pour les points
est-ce que je peux raconter une petite
ligne à l'italier ou tu sacrifie le pion
pour le même structures et c'est une
compensation très bon compromission à
long terme je peux se cadre l'ancien en
ligne
C3 collectif de 3 dci
[Musique]
avec
et maintenant le truc c'est que si
coller H4D
[Musique]
vous
à quoi ça me ressemble mais là du coup
tu peux me faire une attaque en
supériorité numérique sur casse blanche
alors que dans la position de la partie
le fruit va venir couvrir c'est quand
même une grosse différence
mais l'autre différence que pour le
futur prévisible le collier à 5 pas de
le jour
donc il y a pas de problème du fou mais
il y a le problème donc
le cogolais n'est pas si mauvais sur A5
mais ça dépend si les bons vont réussir
de créer une grosse action au centre ou
pas si oui dans ce cas là les Noirs vont
rencontrer cette action au centre sans
une pièce qui est bloquée sur
sur bossette
après de ce qu'on a vu le problème c'est
que les coûts logiques pour les Noirs
tiennent
parce que ce qu'a fait l'ordi c'était
vraiment les coups les plus normaux il a
fait B6 recettes pour 8
bah c'est les coups que je dis à tout à
l'heure tu te rappelles
tout le monde va jouer en fait il y a
pas un coup difficile
dommage mais c'est pour ça que je dis
que c'est vraiment raté de la part de
ligne
parce que oui il est raté quoi mais tu
sais qu'il peut même perdre
est-ce que tu penses que Yann est même
favori maintenant dans cette position
non
je le pense pas je pense maintenant
il y a personne qui favori maintenant
ah c'est dommage quand même cette faute
ça pouvait complètement relancer le
match
bon peut-être que Yann va nous réjouir
aussi
ok une seule bonne nouvelle qui est au
moine
de plus
ce qui est déjà pas mal
le problème avec Yann aussi c'est que
malgré que
Ding a crié depuis au centre comme ça
très poussin
comme il est né en tant que joueur de
grandefield depuis d'habitude le
pionedes
enfin le plus souvent
selon quelqu'un d'autre juridique le
plus d'Amen n'est pas contre le et si on
fait ça
c'est complètement con
bah je fais peut-être
la même chose
si je te respecte
ça veut dire que je dois créer du
contour jouer
ok en fait c'est un truc facile je suis
fait Torah D8 c'est 4 V5
pas très dur
OK et si tu commences avec à 4
au lieu de foot
j'aurais pas le temps
je sais pas
mais en gros je veux autant
je vais vous
[Musique]
c'est trop
il a pas été super malin
bon ok regardons un peu la pause que tu
as dit tout à l'heure c'est intéressant
dans ce 3 tours
d'abord tour des 8 pour partir peut-être
à je crois on l'avait calé quelque part
et on avait joué C4 gagner un tempo
ok disons tout recettes dams 3 tours
mais au lieu de secours exceptionnel un
peu jouer un coup plus ou même fausse 2
fous de cette raison
parce que les pièces les dames H1 H6 et
le four à 5 sont pas mauvais mais il
peut se tourner qu'ils peuvent être très
mal passé y compris parce que si le
centre s'ouvre
on ne peut pas jouer à 6 oui
sauver que parfois 4
sinon tu parles plus en fait et si je
joue Koba
désolé bien sûr
c'est pas la peine d'être trop profond
ça va ça passe
plus de dire
que j'ai pas essayé les moines il y a
plus 5
+ 10 là
bon mais c'est intéressant là la
position la partie ah non ça c'est quoi
ce jeu parce qu'on avait avant enfin moi
je suis très déçu parce qu'on avait
avant toi aussi peut-être bah non je
suis désolé
le truc à deux résultats et qu'on savait
que ça allait durer 5 heures mais je
veux dire soit gain soit nul tu auras de
jouer
alors là
attends on va en fait là on a gagné un
temps c'est 4 B6
H3 x H5
bam C3
il a mis sa tour sur D8 pour repartir en
C8
ça donne la case F3 c'est non peut-être
je viens de dire une autre connerie
parce que ça reste la case
dans ce cas-là
tout ce qu'on a regardé
ok
alors H3 x 5
ok disons est-ce qu'il y a une punition
directe pour ça non
on peut faire pousser deux on a la même
avec un temps de plus
et cavalier 7 en plus si c'est pris la
casse D8 si jamais
mais c'est marrant parce que c'est pas
évident de comprendre comment les blancs
progressent molenoir bouge pas
parce que ici aucun envie de bouger le
pion juin le Pione h bouge pas
le fou je suis la case F3
comment
il a fait C4 explosif
et le fait il a fait
mais regarde il reste assis tout tout le
temps la digue maintenant il se lève
plus du tout il a réparé les chiottes il
est là maintenant
trois jours trois parties et demi il
réussit super mais ça y est finalement
il a trouvé le truc quoi et maintenant
il reste ça y est c'est fixé
ça y est ça coule plus
et bon ça y est je peux jouer au travail
du joueur de chèque à mon au monde
deuxième au moins 2e boulot toi qui
vient du Kazakhstan Vlad est-ce que il y
a des problèmes de plomberie là-bas
généralement ou pas toi qui a vécu toute
ton enfance comme ça demande une blague
je sais pas comment le tourner ok
sérieusement non
mais comment dire
mais il y avait il y avait pas de
problème
mais avant son arrivée
donc il a joué
B5 on y a même pas pensé en fait
tellement bizarre pas même si je joue
danse trop est toujours Bucker dans le
pseudo je suis content
ça va donner cavalier B3 qui a validé 4
et tu vas te faire taper C5 ouais et on
pouvait pas jouer comme les bosser parce
que ce beau tour de 5 x 4 tours de 5
fois 7 important
important non tu ressens
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de différence
entre la langue Casa qui est la langue
russe je crois que c'est juste deux
univers complètement différents
96 donc j'ai oublié plein de choses mais
sinon
les choses primaires je comprends
en fait tout le monde a pris un petit
peu le casaque mais si tu veux c'est un
peu comme ici à l'école ils apprennent
le Russe quoi en gros d'accord tu vas
prendre ils apprennent le Russe ici mais
il le parle pas pour nous c'était pareil
avec le avec le Kazakh à l'époque
donc tu parles tu le comprends un petit
peu quoi du jeu je le comprends un petit
peu au mode déjà je le
Parlement moins bien que que le serpent
[Musique]
il faut juste jouer H3 n'est pas trop
réfléchi aux dames 3 mais il faut pas
dépasser trop de temps parce que dur de
comprendre les différences l'un de deux
le dos coups sont mécaniques j'aurais
dit même et donc c'est pas les points de
se casser la tête parce que de toute
façon c'est pas là où les parties va se
décider donc j'espère que
il faut pas qu'il prenne trop de temps
pour le moment son rythme de jeu a à
Digne et assez cohérent aujourd'hui
c'est impressionnant aujourd'hui il est
normal quoi
aujourd'hui il est normal
[Musique]
c'est bien
c'est le moment important de la partie
là qui va arriver
pas mal de choses peuvent et peut-être
doivent se décider dans les 7 8 Go à
venir
soit le petit avantage blanc voit
s'agrandir jusqu'à la taille
conséquente alarmante quoi soit les
Noirs vont continuer de garder leur
comme quoi forteresse et donc et puis
peut-être l'avantage blanc voit se
diminuer le
l'extropion pour le noir est toujours là
quand même donc c'est peut-être même pas
8 mais cette cour à venir sont de
l'importance critique pour l'issue de la
partie en fait par contre je ne vois pas
du tout Yann l'emporter en réalité
beaucoup non mais genre on a été on a eu
un peu peur à un moment donné
on a eu peur
mais
il est vrai les tricky
mais par contre ici il y a pas trop de
trucs
par là on est plus on n'est pas à
l'armiste du tout quoi
au bon moment ça fait plaisir oui moi en
fait je pense qu'il faut réfléchir un
petit peu plus tard comme je dis
pour un enterrement de comprendre dame
sur 3 watch 3 maintenant c'est trop tôt
par contre une chose de moi je refais
d'abord
parce que je garde ça tout simplement
parce que je me suis dit peut-être avant
notre 3 je vais faire d'eau
et après réfléchir
c'est vrai que tu es peut-être même
jamais oublié de jouer oui il faut se
donner
à mon avis
des deux côtés
est-ce que tu penses que c'est le moment
de la pause
je pense que c'est le moment de la pause
comme ça on va avoir la petite annonce
chez sarahma et nous on va un peu récup
et on vient dans une dizaine de minutes
à tout de suite les amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs nous sommes de
retours qui va arriver on a fait le
petit café la petite la petite minute
détente la petite minuterie en premier
bon après on l'avait dit c'était une
histoire de goût mais il a préféré
commencer par par le quoi H3 possible la
qui arrive
le rayon donc bon ça va même si je
préférais dans 3
bah c'était l'un ou l'autre mais les
deux étaient au menu déjà elle a fait ça
c'est rapidement
il se passe rien surtout franchement si
il se passe beaucoup de choses surtout
point H3 après je crois puis on prend H3
dame frappe je crois il se passerait la
chose suivante c'est que les Blancs
gagnent une pièce pour rien
ok il faut F5 c'est le plus simple
d'ailleurs qui est un peu être un bon
réflexe de défense aussi
pour le public on va dire ok faut F5
c'est le coup le plus fort probablement
et fou F1 et foug2 ça généralement quand
on voit ça arriver ça blinde et c'est
les meilleurs le meilleur film que j'ai
jamais vu demain donc les deux après
faire gaffe de pas perdre 5 peu importe
mais c'est juste pour vous expliquer
rapidement et facilement Yann qui est
revenu Ding qui a quitté sa chaise une
heure il reste une heure pour les deux
joueurs à après 19 coups 1h03 1h06 il
faut H5 jouets donc
si t'as pas voulu mettre ton fou sur ce
8 mais tu as toujours voulu mettre sur
H5
pourquoi ta photo
il a fait tour à de 8 pour qu'il y a
plus de faux bus 5 mais on se demande
est-ce qu'il faut pour sang qui a été si
dangereux
mais comme quoi il est donc bloqué
C2
c'est que tout à fait un réflexe dans
programmer tout à fait
ce que tu veux faire trop logique ouais
c'est vraiment trop logique voilà tu
sais j'ai remarqué quelque chose enfin
c'est une règle que j'ai eu dans un
livre mais c'est souvent vrai
généralement quand il te reste qu'un des
deux fous donc là en l'occurrence le
foot casse blanche tu aimes bien avoir
ta dame sur une case noire pour
contrôler les diagonales des deux
couleurs
belle formule tu l'avais déjà lu
instinctivement
je sais pas bien pour de téléphone je
sais qu'il en existe plein mais je
connais peut-être 10 fois moins que toi
beaucoup moins fort que toi donc pour
expliquer
mais c'est pour ça que c'est un réflexe
qu'on a c'est de c'est logique tu veux
contrôler les deux couleurs maintenant
une petite question interparentes après
dame ce 3 si jamais il peut pas
s'activer essayer de s'activer je
n'arrive pas
mais j'adore ce que fait l'ordi c'est
beau j'ai quatre fougères 6 fois
bouffer repartir
tu trouves en partie ça
on va quand même
et si tu vois pas tout adhérent attends
il a joué
mais je vois pas trop l'intérêt
maintenant il y a tout 7 autour de 8
mais ça transpose dans ce qu'on a
regardé en fait ça transpose dans ton
recettes dame C3 tours 8 x 2 comme il a
perdu en tant que ça nous on perd un
temps comme ça lui il a fait ça et ça
par rapport à la ligne et nous on a fait
ça et ça
en fait qui viennent il avait peur de
toi
donc
c'était quand même
oui mais c'est élégant et le joueur de
ce que souvent vont pas de choses
lesquelles
parce que tu dois comprendre ton ADN et
tu rebouffes avec la dame c'est ça
l'idée parce que sinon tu vois quoi tu
vois je peux pas bouffer avec les dames
le câble dedans prise sur collectroit il
y a peut-être H5
c'est ça le problème et quand bien même
[Musique]
et toujours pas de problème
bon
peut-être ça
il joue cette après avoir sacrifié le
pion pour une grosse compensation
maintenant H3 x 4 etc c'est un peu ce
qu'on appelle
sous couvercle
il veut le mettre sous couvercle
il veut tout faire
ouais mais bon
c'est peut-être trop
c'est peut-être on a le fac qui est en
train d'arriver
on nous rejoindre on va voir ce qu'il en
pense
c'est toujours le moment difficile dans
ces parties pour commenter parce que
c'est
la pression augmente mais ça augmente
lentement quoi
mais ça reste quand même beaucoup plus
agréable au blanc OK
pourquoi le feu aussi première raison ce
poste comme ça il est à notre les aider
de soi sinon
il voit que tu recettes est devenu
possible maintenant mais il a vu avant
au cours de la partie
n'est pas trop chaud pour je te recettes
justement à cause de cette idée et puis
le fou va toucher la tour sur 8 par A4
donc
une chose est claire
en ce moment-là
est plus content que l'autre
nous on le connait pas non plus ou parce
que tu dois dire que c'est au moins 0,5
je pense quand tu joues mais quand tu
joues tu penses que c'est bon
un petit avantage
00 bon
déjà je suis pas sûr que c'est le cas tu
peux ouvrir aux femmes comme tu es plus
ouais non je sais pas c'est difficile à
dire
mais tu penses que tu es mieux ça c'est
sûr avec les Blancs après à quel point
compliqué
on prend il y aurait à 5 pour fermer la
colonne donc ça on a plus
ne veut pas trop en ce moment là on veut
pas trop échanger ce cavalier
parce que en espère que une fois il va
arriver sur F3 il va bien demander le
pion au centre et pour
plus tard participer à l'attaque parce
que je vous rappelle encore une fois
en détail très important stratégiquement
dans cette position là c'est que pour
l'instant les Noirs bloquent le progrès
des blancs pour l'instant c'est pas
comment les bonbons percer mais
qu'est-ce que ce serait cool pour le
noir de quand même sécuriser le roi un
petit peu en bougeant le pion h
où j'ai mais une possibilité
ne sont pas possible quoi
j'ai 5
[Musique]
pose trop la cavisme n'ont pas pourri
sinon non ça va être juste mauvais
donc et c'est chiant quand même pour un
bon opticien parce que il sait que quand
les positions versus va se chauffer
ça va être une facture très importante
que le papy est sensible il est très
sensible dans tous les jeux pas eux 6 ou
D6 et le centre s'ouvre et le papier
à mon nez juste pour montrer un scénario
un peu à la con quoi mais admettons je
sais pas je cherche un coup de tour
débile disons à 6 en fait même là genre
ça juste pour montrer à quel point le
Roi peut être mal placé
et si on joue Roy F8 on aura d'autres
problèmes notamment sur dame C3 on se
met en face et quand le cavalier arrive
en G5 il tape F7
non le roi est sensible à très très
longtemps d'ailleurs regarde sur G8
donc ça veut dire qu'il a pas vraiment
de bonne case ici
qui serait mieux ici peut-être
pas
mais dur à faire
les choses le plus évident dans tout le
monde
ah ouais et très très important aussi
nos chers amis c'est que le noir veulent
pas vraiment jouer faut chiffres où je
suis très important concours les Noirs
ça blinde et après les blondes donc
progresse
on va organiser tour c'est un protégé
absolument pas jouer fou je suis et
comme ça peut-être pendant longtemps
mais pour c'est un jeu actif
il y a des jeux pour qui c'est facile de
ne rien faire
normalement c'est pas lui il a un peu le
même
pour rien faire
non mais écoute
toute ma vie j'ai eu plus ou moins le
même problème mais quand tu as rien à
faire bah ok tu fais rien bah disons tu
fais tout recettes
tu repart autour de 8 tu vois ta mère
alors quoi et tu croises
toi tu es plutôt un joueur actif que
passif aussi oui j'étais toujours
mauvais
un peu dire même près un mauvais
indéfense
quoi ça a été compensé par le fait c'est
que presque à tout prix éviter ça
mais qui est bon en défense passive
c'est dur
Wesley
ouais
peut-être très bien
parfois parfois
beaucoup beaucoup nagas oui bien sûr
parce que ce sont la nature
C3 sont limites
donc c'est vrai que
d'ailleurs de eux tous c'est le joueur
mette moi le plus possible
oui elle a rien contre
il n'a pas grand chose
non non il est pas décédé mais il joue
plus quoi
je sais pas si il a le droit de jouer
d'ailleurs oui il a de nouveau le droit
de jouer
l'état de choses avec les sanctions
contre lui moi je pense normalement il y
a plus de Samsung contre 6 mois non il a
été ban six mois oui et donc je pense
que le bon n'existe plus moi il est vrai
il joue plus par contre quand il y a des
tournois rapides oublient de sa Russie
il les fait à chaque fois je pense si
c'est fort il a des bons résultats ou
pas oui
oui le dernier grand tournoi
Blitz rapide combiné il a gagné
devant n'est pas
moi gris chou que jouer puis je suppose
de beauf à jouer
celui qui a gagné
en fait
oui il a fait un truc incroyable même ça
femme lui a dit que c'était vraiment pas
correct j'entame un beat contre lui en 3
+ 0 ok je joue je joue et on se retrouve
avec tour 3 pions tours trois pions sur
la même aile mais il me restait 5
secondes contre 10 il m'a fait tomber
si tu veux en 99 c'était le championnat
de Bled je joue contre un pôle année
c'était un Varsovie et j'ai l'opium E6
roi de 6 ou les rois de 8 et le reste de
secondes il me regarde
je me suis dit gagner ou pas gagné et je
fais cette huîtres ici
c'est pas en tournoi c'est différent
voilà c'était bon dans mon cas c'était
pas amical d'ailleurs moi j'ai encore
des news c'est pas que je suis le mec le
plus correctement je pense que j'ai eu
deux ou trois histoires c'est celle de
ma part c'est vrai d'ailleurs une des
très marrante je peux raconter tant que
c'est le temps ok je joue le championnat
du monde de Junior avant de moins de 20
ans et à la deuxième bronze joue contre
quelqu'un a assez nettement moins fort
que moi moi je regarde pas de le prouver
et donc je comprends que ça va être nul
il vous reste 5 minutes et je propose
nul donc il réfléchit il réfléchit il
réfléchit
et c'était avant les pendule digital oui
c'est avec le drapeau quoi et donc
il va perdre et donc il me tend la mort
j'aurais tant aimé je touche ses doigts
avec mes doigts comme ça comme sur le
sur le tableau de Michel-Ange et puis je
vois que son drapeau est tombé
je reprends maman je dis tomber
je l'ai touché quoi
ok finalement j'ai gagné mais je sais
pas fier que le Dieu me pardonne mais
c'est beau quoi
j'ai touché quoi
et puis après il y avait une très très
longue investigation ça durait des
heures et des heures à un moment donné
un interne en voiture il m'a dit mais
mec
toi tu as tombé et donc il y a eu cette
discussion OK
de toi quand même au moment où tu l'as
fait non pas du tout
je voulais encaisser mon point
et l'autre histoire tu as dit que tu en
avais deux trois
à un moment donné un joli le championnat
du monde de Blitz en Croatie
c'est très important c'est un Croate
avec qui j'ai passé plusieurs soirées
ensemble en gros de mes potes ok je joue
contre le ski et je tombe autant mais il
me reste quelques secondes c'était aussi
avant les pointures et
un moment donné donc il y a
tout cavalier et point pion pour Madame
mais je fais semblant comme quoi c'est
le perpète et ok je donne
le jeudi perpète
je le dis attends mais quel perpette
[Musique]
et l'arbitre a dit qu'il s'est passé
ils viennent
plus tard
[Rires]
il devait pas être bien oui donc c'est
une deuxième histoire celle-là
et la troisième non il faut me rappeler
mais je veux me rappeler mais c'est deux
histoires oui c'est vrai que elles sont
belles
[Rires]
c'est beau tu connais les arbitres quoi
c'est le soir
en fait
[Rires]
[Musique]
ouais c'est beau mais bon l'autre quand
tu as touché j'ai touché
c'est beau
non ça réfléchit toujours un côté n'est
pas
faut pas sortir du contexte cette phrase
j'ai juste touché mais pas serré quoi
[Rires]
ça peut
j'ai juste touché les
[Rires]
c'est trop
bah pourtant
nos amis
la différence au temple devient assez
conséquente conséquente parce que quand
même
de différence presque
mais surtout c'est une position qui
n'est pas peut très mal jouer et en quoi
vaincourt à jouer et ça va pas être
évident de jouer la suite de la partie
pour le noir ici c'est que c'est il est
clair il
faudra faire de décision pas facile
teleter les positions les positions de
ce qu'on appelle très responsable
mais des histoires sales subit
pareil
[Musique]
avec le même mec que la deuxième
histoire
à noter aller en voir sa vie de jouer le
championnat du monde de Blitz
et à l'époque si tu te rappelles il y
avait une règle
que aussi tu touches une pièce sur mon
temple que tu es perdu tout de suite
il y avait ça fonctionnait pendant genre
2 ans
et nous pendant les violons pendant
qu'il y en a pris le taxi etc on a
discuté
cette de cette règle là ouais et pendant
et donc et pendant les parties
automotiquement il a fait comme toute sa
vie il a fait il a il a fait son coup il
a appuyé sur le pendule sa pièce tombée
il a il a du bruit quoi il me regarde
comme quoi je veux alors
ou pas
et
je me suis dit ok mais c'est un pote
quand même et
je l'ai pas reconnu mais je m'entendais
que dans ce cas là il joue avec les
bandances qu'elle a elle va me proposer
une
donc il fallait il fallait faire quoi
bah en gros
quelle est la conclusion de cette
histoire bah aux échecs
non mais je pense que la conclusion
c'est pas ça c'est il vaut mieux être un
connard en premier
parce que tu sais jamais si l'autre va
faire
donc il vaut mieux commencer quoi
ça a été aussi c'est que une fois je
l'ai eu déjà oui
pour le reste de sa vie j'aurais été
associé avec les les actions pas très
catholiques ouais mais ça faisait Punto
et en plus j'ai grave prétendu pour les
premières places pendant tout le tournoi
il faut les concurrence avec un bol
d'ailleurs donc il était premier moi
j'étais premier le premier une fois j'ai
perdu ce match ça y est je suis parti du
tracer quand même en fait au final
méritait mérite quoi d'avoir perdu cette
partie
donc en quelque sorte il y a pas fait il
a pas fonctionné comme épaules qui ont
gagné toujours mais comment nouveau mais
pour
parce que sinon avant on est le recette
au bout de quelques secondes donc
maintenant j'espère que Ding va être
pratique
ah mais regarde le bide qui arrive
c'est impressionnant quand même tu as vu
le but s'impose
c'est pour ça Ding il a l'air tellement
petit et chétif en face de ne pas
incroyable non
je connaissais pas le motif c'est un
joli
pas besoin de le traduire il se comprend
tout seul j'adore les mots comme ça
chétif tu comprends tout ça même pas
besoin d'expliquer
la conférence de presse aussi il est
beaucoup plus discret ouais on a écouté
la conférence de presse hier et ce qui
est marrant de les conférences de presse
c'est que nepo est le seul à parler
correctement anglais
et le seul à mentir sur chaque mois ah
il ment tout le temps il ne fait que
mentir
juste
c'est même pas la peine de chercher où
il ment parce que
il a raison
en quelque sorte oui en quelque sorte
non en fait parce que quand tu ne fais
pas que mentir
ça laisse enfin je pense qu'il faut
mentir mais parfois un peu en petite
dose pour au moins donner de la bouffe
aux autres
qui vont essayer de décrypter ou tu mens
ou pas parce que par exemple les lundis
que il est analysé tout le monde il se
préparait tout le monde parce que ce
produit hier on a tous vu hier que c'est
pas du tout ça
c'est trop
mais bon après il a pas tort dans le
sens au moins il donne aucune
information à personne mais oui c'est
conférence de presse elles n'ont aucun
intérêt
ni le récit
quelqu'un qui
[Rires]
moi
les conférences de presseaux aussi nul
que je sais pas
c'est nul ouais un peu moins nul quand
même mais assez nul
sauf boxe
c'est marrant mais dans les sports
généralement c'est pas c'est pas fou
mais non c'est difficile tu peux pas
demander aux sportif d'être honnête
parce que ça les pénalise en fait
je trouve que parce que je sais tu as du
moins de parler parfois
à chaud tout de suite après les parties
mais déjà c'est plus intéressant quand
c'est les entraîneurs que quand c'est
les joueurs on serait peut-être plus
intéressant d'avoir des
conférences de presse des seconds
peut-être serait plus intéressant que
les joueurs et ça dépend quel type de ce
content
tu peux poser plus de questions est-ce
que vous aviez tu peux plus les pages
quoi ça c'est le premier truc et
et deuxièmement j'allais dire un autre
truc à fabriquer donc ça et ouais aussi
les conférences de presse parfois ça
puisse retourner contre des gens genre
par exemple au cyclisme il y a je me
rappelle plus quel coureur français mais
en fait c'était Paris-Nice et un mec a
gagné deux étapes coup sur coup en
s'échappant ok c'est clair pour tout le
monde qu'il est d'opé en fait et il
demande à un cycliste un Français qui
répond juste après la course il a pris
réagir il dit oui performance
extraordinaire je vais pas redire le nom
du gars il gagne deux étapes coup sur
coup magistral bon bah il lui dit ouais
enfin bon je sais pas à quoi il tourne
quoi mais je pense pas que ce soit à
l'eau ou quelque chose comme ça et il
s'est carrément pris une réprimande
enfin c'était chaud pour lui il a failli
se faire bannir à cause de ça tu
sous-entends qu'il triche très grave
donc en fait c'est pas facile aussi
parce que si tu réponds franchement bah
tu prends des risques donc au bout d'un
moment bah il faut aller vous faire
en fait très fort oui il est
vraiment très très fort spécialiste
spécialiste spécialiste de Paris
mes chers amis à vendre c'est ma place à
mon collègue enfin un autre collègue Fab
je voudrais juste vous poser une
question il y a des gens qui savent dans
qui ont la rêve dans le chat de ces deux
étapes c'est incroyable en fait c'est tu
gagnes deux étapes hyper dur coup sur
coup tu t'échappes tu défonces tout le
monde oui bon merci au revoir quoi
ok plus tard ah allez peut-être je veux
me rejoindre un peu plus tard je laisse
ma place
et merci sarde pour pour le sub pourquoi
je suis seul à cette chaîne personne ne
sait mais peut-être tu as toujours su
mais ouais donc du coup ça donne pas
envie d'être honnête en fait
si l'honnêteté par récompensé et que
quand on attaque en diffamation ou
je ne sais quoi ouais ils sont très
forts
merci au revoir quoi qu'est-ce que tu
veux dire d'autre
c'est chiant mais ouais
du coup c'était pourquoi c'était parce
que poser des questions sur les
conférences de presse ici que je disais
c'est quoi la question non parler juste
des conférences de presse en général
tu veux pas donner d'info à ton
adversaire bah c'est pour ça que je dis
en fait il y a pas de cas où être
honnête et intéressant
c'est jamais récompensé quasiment hein
c'est rarement récompensé l'honnêteté
donc ça devrait
mais et ça se voit dans beaucoup de
domaines
même pour analyser les parties vaut
mieux enfin en fait je pense vaut mieux
bullshit tout le temps quoi c'est plus
internet mais vraiment faut juste
prendre les gens pour des cons tout le
temps c'est c'est le plus efficace après
tu peux avoir envie de le faire ou ne
pas le faire mais je pense vraiment que
je trouve globalement c'est beaucoup
plus efficace prendre les gens pour des
cons c'est beaucoup plus efficace
bon après tu as de
t'as une descente ou pas quoi dire
globalement c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
et du coup alors cette partie ça fait
longtemps qu'on est bloqué sur en fait
on a cette position nous on a eu cette
position avec un autre ordre de coup
mais la danse étroite ou pareil ouais
mais tout pareil étourd de 8 ou C2 mais
il y a genre avant qu'on fasse la pause
il me semble j'avais vu cette option
quand j'ai juste regardé
c'est à dire que nous ça fait 55 minutes
qu'on a cette position donc on a un peu
flemme tu vois de
jouer votre coup quoi
[Musique]
un statu quo à venir ou ça va bouger a
priori non c'est mieux pour les blancs
très clairement pas mieux plus facile à
jouer non en fait avec les Noirs
tu dois faire statu quo n'a avec les
Blancs tu as quand même le droit de
jouer quelques coups
surtout F3 hein c'est ce que dit leur
dit mais bon c'est fou c'est de le coup
parfois 4 faces c'est juste trop évident
parce que
ton fous sur la case du cavalier et je
sais pas s'il fait même fouger 6 il va
commencer à menacer dame G5 je sais pas
nous ça nous a pas paru manqué alors dit
il fait fouder oui bon oui bon à quatre
aussi en fait 3
non mais c'est très très bien joué mais
oui bien sûr la ligne numéro 1 de l'ordi
va toujours être l'idée mais bon enfin
l'idée c'est fou ces deux s'y trouve un
c'est la même idée
ce mur de pion qui
mais en fait moi ce que j'ai pour
expliquer la position que tu accompagnes
bien en fait là tu as le mur Maria et
peut-être que tout d'un coup tu as des
tu as de la lumière qui vient dessus tu
as les Titans Colosso qui se mettent à
avancer bon déjà les deux des cinq ça
fait 250 ils sont Colosso ça te suffit
mais tu as tous les Titans Colosso qui
viennent derrière ils arrivent ils
arrivent ils marchent à fond enfin et
tout ça enfin ils vont tous être là il
nage
[Musique]
tout à l'heure après la pause
c'est le grand terrassement tu sens un
grand terrassement qui arrive quoi après
ce qui aura réussi à arrêter
on sait pas quoi enfin eux ils veulent
peut-être avancer mais vont-ils
en tout cas on sent qu'ils peuvent
sortir des murs à tout moment et marcher
quoi enfin
disait aussi Fougères
bien vu j'ai misery
des option après il y avait nettement
plus fort
en fait quand il a sacrifié le pion il y
avait un damacade qui est B3 qui était
hyper fort juste tactique ou non mais en
fait c'est l'autre truc qui était facile
mais juste on peut en discuter le
problème c'est que
c'est qu'en fait ça ça a l'air bien en
fait si tu as pas ça l'autre tu le
trouves facilement mais comme ça
mais l'autre était plus fort moins
risqué juste à pas de bol d'avoir ça en
fait c'est pas de bol parce que l'autre
c'était plus 0,7 + 0,8 et égalité
matérielle et là tu as filé un vieux
quand même et puis c'est que plus 0,2 ou
+ 0,3 mais du coup ça c'est pas de bol
quoi
pour
expliquer plusieurs fois mais juste si
échangent ben les cavalier trouve la
case F3 et on va juste faire tout reca
tour 1 Dame des deux et encaisser le
pion et
le problème c'est que ce cavalier à 5 il
est vraiment mal placé la tour 4 elle va
défendre le pion C4 elle va attaquer le
pion F4 mais est-ce que ça arrive
cavalier à 5 soit bien placé en fait
c'est hyper rare mais le nombre de pas
qu'on voit ou l'autre il est là-bas il
bouge pas et
puis il te coûte cher à la fin
c'est terrible
ouais c'est
devant un max et stats je crois que
depuis un moment il a arrêté de le faire
parce que justement
ça marchait pas trop mais réussi à le
faire un peu marcher tactiquement dans
certaines positions mais depuis alpha
zéro bah il y a une très bonne partie
que vous pouvez retrouver sur la chaîne
c'était gris Chuck mvl ça devait être au
Grand Prix du Grand Prix de Riga vous
pouvez retrouver sur la chaîne blitzrim
et grichu qui a gagné une partie
vraiment modèle contre le cavalier à 5
c'est 60 coups contre le cavalier
donc je sais pas quoi
[Musique]
en tout cas la partie on s'en rappelle
oui mais je vois que tu parles
et c'était sûr que c'était grish ou
blanc c'était une prépa assez longue
qui était bien cadré parce qu'il avait
su que Maxime ferait cavalière
toute la partie contre
donc candidat agritude
probablement poussé de là qui va arriver
si troufouette
il pensait depuis un mois
a priori ils vont jouer
mais ouais ouais moi je me céderais pas
mega à l'aise avec les Noirs parce que
en fait tu
n'as rien à jouer tu attends de te faire
taper quoi il est blanc ils peuvent
améliorer gentiment pas si gentiment que
ça en fait c'est hyper fort c'est dur
c'est vraiment dur mais ça avec
comme tu dis il réfléchit depuis
longtemps et comme fou C2 c'est vraiment
le truc que tu as envie de faire avec la
main si tu réfléchis tu peux dire à dire
je vais être plus malin ça tu peux
trouver du coup
parce que sur cette position et ça vient
45000 qui réfléchit donc c'est
mais du coup il se fait deux jours qu'il
est plus si confortable tout d'un coup
malgré le bide malgré le bide bon
ça se passe plus comme les deux
premières rondes quoi je suis sûr que
les joueurs ont eu à quelqu'un qui parle
de la salle de repos c'est sûr qu'ils
ont eu des remontrances pour leur dire
qu'il fallait qu'ils arrêtent
deux secondes un peu prendre un jus
faire un truc mais c'est pas moi même
une heure sur les quatre heures dans ta
salle de repos si tu veux mais ça peut
pas être
tu peux pas passer deux heures et demie
ou trois heures sur 4 heures dedans
est-ce que c'est cette partie c'est
peut-être en bourre est-ce que c'est ça
là on va voir
oui c'est cette partie ouais
donc c'était Hambourg mais c'est bien un
Grand Prix fine
celle là on l'avait fait ouais je me
rappelle la partie extraordinaire
je pense c'est enfin c'est une des
premières enfin pas une des premières
fois mais c'est là où ils un moment ou
avec Alpha 08 on commence à punir ses
cavaliers à 5 de manière vraiment
précise et direct
l'info chat était bonne non parce qu'ils
ont dit ils ont dit candidats donc non
ça pourrait valoir bandaf évidemment
mais c'était bien un Grand Prix ouais
quelqu'un a dit en bourse possible ça
après c'est possible qu'ils aient
recherche et trouver la partie mais
ouais elle est belle c'est une belle
partie à voir et à revoir longue longue
longue mais qui a jamais revenu en jeu
quoi
c'était incroyable il était là-bas puni
au coin mais il est arrivé là-bas 15 16
et la partie durée 80 coups il a jamais
joué en plus trouver un coup actif
il calcule F3
on a déjà parlé aussi à un moment de ça
c'est les mêmes choses qui reviennent
mais là il y a pas le G4 juste
G3 j'ai 4 ça passe
non mais en fait F3 je sais pas mais oui
j'ai faim
il va juste se faire bouffer tout seul
enfin là c'est juste trois tours
maintenant j'ai pas je trouve ça fait
aucun sens FF 3
mais si les blancs peuvent se mettre
comme ça à tout défendre
il manquait quoi agritude pour aller
jusqu'au match champion bah il a failli
c'est le match contre Gael Fanta qui
perd bêtement mais ouais il a été c'est
plus que proche il aurait dû y aller en
fait je pense parce que il est quand
même plus fort
donc il aurait pu faire
et puis c'est circonstances quoi là
circonstance négative
ah mais c'est chaud de vrai
juste avant
au numéro 1 de mondial à ce moment-là
dans le jeu mais ouais c'est ça se joue
sur un match sur une partie ça joue sur
un coup quoi
ça rend le coup normal il faut F3 c'est
le coup
normal plus fort
on va voir de toute façon
mais cette fois sur le truc c'est qu'il
a dû la voir en tête il y a déjà un long
moment oui
quand même si passe une demi-heure
dessus il faut F3 au lieu de fou c'est
toi c'est quand même trouvé
ça parce que
je pense que après avoir passé 30 ou 40
minutes de suite tu peux quand même
avoir froid quoi
[Musique]
il nous dit j'ai l'impression que non on
était peut-être pas si impressionnant
que ça non il était vraiment fort le
problème c'est canon de il est vieux
quoi et il y a 10 ans de ça il était
déjà vieux et déjà il était encore il
était encore là
non bah quand il arrivait il jouait tout
tempo c'est parti hyper bien il défoncé
quasi tout le monde et ça fait depuis le
début des années 90 il est
[Musique]
je pars dans les trois meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux
et donc il est très impressionnant mais
en fait quand tu commences à t'approcher
de 55 ans c'est
un peu plus dur quoi déjà même là il
joue largement à plus de 2007 toujours
quand il joue il joue bien il joue peu
maintenant il est retraité quasiment
quoi
53 piges le pape fait de la résistance
hein parce que déjà plus de 40 ans c'est
dur
bon
donc
[Musique]
il était vraiment impressionnant
du Championnat du Monde 95 quoi tu vois
j'arrive pas à situer au niveau de
grishal en star mvl il alterne est parti
impeccable et des gros trous d'air bon
on gris de chat c'était enfin il y avait
pas trop de trumeurs mais maintenant
pareil aussi comme tout le monde mais il
a quatre enfants quand même
champion du monde enfin bon de Blitz
mais quand même quoi
c'était vraiment impressionnant la
congridsa il était 28 quelque chose
c'était fou son niveau
non mais Grisha il a clairement été
numéro 2 net en fait
un moment donné
après je sais pas si à son top et tu
vois tu prends
un cramique slash and prime est-ce que
c'est nettement plus fort que gris tu
quand même normalement ouais je pense
mais bon ils sont pas vraiment
rencontrés à ce moment-là mais ça doit
être au-dessus mais Grisha il a il a
vraiment eu une grosse fenêtre pour être
champion du monde bah ouais ouais
[Musique]
le souvenir des gens en 2001 il jouait
le match contre
l'époque
non non
et à un moment où il a été à son top et
voilà
mais il a vraiment eu un shot pour pour
le titre avec la réussite il aurait été
au moins finaliste de championnats du
monde voire même gagnant il était
vraiment un coup quoi oui après non
c'est pas fait mais je veux dire c'est
genre 55 ans
on saura jamais
10 ça fait 7 8 fois les candidats Grisha
je sais pas j'ai pas compté
il en a fait plusieurs alors après j'ai
pas compté mais
fondament c'était quoi les pronoms
j'imagine très à Nantes quoi
ils avaient un matchup c'est un match
pourri pour galfendre leur historique
était catastrophique c'était
complètement en faveur de Hanan parce
que c'est un genre assez tactique
cinq candidats pour gricho ouais c'est
déjà énorme surtout qu'il a peut-être eu
une époque il a pas eu de candidat ou un
truc comme ça c'était les matchs
je vais peut-être répondre pour toi Fab
qu'est-ce qui t'a manqué dans ta
carrière pour être top dans le top 10
tout quoi pas mal de choses j'ai pas
menacé en fait
mais c'est dur à me menacer
mais tu sais tu me donneras sponsor
2850 200900 pourquoi pas 3000 au moins
2850 1850
[Musique]
ça n'a pas été une balade de santé même
également de gagner la première partie
il a tout de suite implosé dans celle
d'après angafon oui c'était la sorte de
sa Michele
mais en fait le truc qui est marrant
cette partie là c'est que je j'étais au
boulot je travaillais
et en sortant du travail je devais aller
voir la partie
de sortir du travail plus je m'étais mis
d'accord pour pour arrêter le boulot
plutôt ce jour-là pour avoir le temps
d'aller voir la partie
et j'ai même pas eu le temps parce que
je suis tombé sur la seule partie qui
durait 2 heures
je suis arrivé c'était déjà terminé donc
j'ai pas pu assister à la game
et après il y a que des nul non et des
partages machin j'ai pas eu
mais ouais mais je crois que ouais non
on n'avait pas très bien joué ce match
en fait par rapport à ce qu'il devrait
non mais déjà il était tellement au
dessus de galfun
complètement son match ça avait suffi
parce qu'il
y avait trop de
d'historique entre les deux hommes
bon
c'est vrai que je suis là j'ai pas vu
grand chose quoi
on était vraiment sur la position il y a
plus d'une heure déjà donc bon il faut
être plus fort mais là la partie il faut
que des couz joue pour qu'il y ait de
nouveau des choses intéressantes à
raconter
21 coups 40 minutes ouais bon ça va mais
si on fait sans parti tout de suite
c'est quoi le ratio à la fin je pense on
fait sans nul non ah bah oui
la question c'est combien de coups vont
durer les parties
[Musique]
je me repose aujourd'hui pas de mot
aussi tiens mais bon tu as trois bails
sur le championnat mais ok là tu prends
ton bail quand tu veux mais comme un
temps mort quoi il a trouvé
le focus peut-être quand même pas
[Musique]
c'est quoi 75 25
en fait on ferait mieux en fait ni l'un
ni l'autre on aura envie de jouer quoi
donc
[Musique]
il joue bien quoi
non mais
je pense 75 25 80 20 non chose comme ça
je sais pas je trouve ça beaucoup des
gens mais bon après l'envie de faire des
petites nulles quand même surré
tellement fort
j'accepte vraiment ce score quoi ce
serait beau que tu mènes un zéro après
99 minutes
ok peut-être que fuj6 c'est trop chiant
là les histoires tout G4 foutent rien
que la dame elle bouge pas trop
bon il menace quand même de ressortir en
D6 ouais mais si je te prends un
cavalier F3 en fait juste ah c'est le
truc logique et du coup je protège
ok normal
ok on va jouer le coup de l'ordi là F5
je sais pas enfin j'ai juste pas d'idée
et tu dois vouloir surtout redonner tu
veux qu'il y ait des 6 mais ouais mais
ce que tu l'as vraiment mais tu vas voir
mais tu vas nulle part
ça alors
si je me mets comme ça
est-ce que c'est genre une forteresse
je vois pas comment rentrer déjà
pour faire quoi
cette idée de G5 je sais pas ça me
paraît logique ok bon ça c'est vite
concret mais
bon je prends les blancs quand même
parce que tu vas faire tout un disons H5
et des deux
tu vas revenir en 4 et en fait c'est
pour ça que j'aimerais bien provoquer la
4 à 5 pour quand je vienne en E4 je me
note de prendre en décises et tu as pas
envie de faire ses prendre et si tu
m'échanges en fait tu peux prendre quand
même c'est un truc attends il a joué
ok bon pourquoi pas peut-être ça change
pas des masses hein
non ok mais si vous voulez jouer 4
[Musique]
ça va tu veux faire ton tour
et il insiste sur cette position
à quatre pour commencer déjà non mais ça
recommence bah de toute façon ce que je
m'en fous d'avoir perdu deux thèmes toi
j'en ai absolument
parce que les Noirs ils ont pas trop de
quoi casser si on fera rien
pas maintenant peut-être même
qu'il s'en fout tu peux pas rentrer
avec sisi il faut prendre
c'est quoi c'est des G5 qui partent
[Musique]
non mais après c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant de savoir si on casse la
position ou pas mais
en tout cas c'est que du jeu à des
résultats
ça pas non ça a l'air
c'est même les positions
[Musique]
je comprends que tu aies pas envie de
laisser
après je sais pas où il va vraiment
mais je comprends que tu veuilles pas
laisser ça
[Musique]
ça passe pas juste à côté et c'est tout
et sinon c'est plus 3 sinon c'est juste
fini aussi
OK
il y a le dame c'est que c'est pas si
facile à jouer
tellement pas envie avec les Noirs après
si ça tient ça
[Musique]
le truc qui est dommage avec les Blancs
c'est que tu as pas le temps d'échanger
aussi ce que tu as dedans en l'air
ok on va y retomber dedans plus ou moins
non mais il peut te garder le fou
parce que je me dis lui il sert à rien
quoi mais je sais pas à quel point en
fait mais bon
une pièce de plus sur l'échiquier
donc c'est pas évident que ce soit si
c'est génial avec toi
bon ici il fait ça
[Musique]
je peux comprendre tu as réussi pas à
avancer et il pousse ouais mais attends
c'était vraiment le seul moment où toute
façon c'était l'attend il peut le faire
quand il veut
je sais pas quoi lui dire
trouver là ça c'est très très bien
défendu par
mais ouais donc eux si il faut le faire
parce que comme tu l'avais montré c'est
tout ravin il y a les échanges et le
clouage à la fin avec 6
donc
complexe
bah le problème c'est qu'on a déjà un
pion de moi et sur rendre une finale
avec un pion de moins bah c'est pas top
2 tu vois que le Cayenne en D6 ils ont
une bonne finale les Noirs C4 c'est
faible tu as le mauvais fou
[Musique]
ça va pas ça va pas trop bien se passer
cette finale quoi
c'est pas que tu perds sur le champ mais
tu vas la perdre quoi
donc a priori ouais il va faire aussi
enfin il y a juste pas le choix en fait
et donc E6 on a dit quoi donc on est pas
sûr qu'il va faire et s'il fait qu'il y
ait des sites sinon plus je sais pas je
trouve ça plus logique
à 4 mais je sais pas si
[Musique]
il y a ce plan aussi qui montre que
j'aime bien
et je peux pas donner des qualités c'est
comme ça
[Musique]
ça me donner l'impression que ça a l'air
pas mal
il me fait peur
on va voir s'il veut garder les fous
n'est pas ça c'est important en fait
j'imagine choisir quelle pièce garde ou
pas
et je sais pas trop en fait je leur dis
il aime bien faire fouger 6 mais moi je
sais pas si j'aime bien
et qu'on crée
F5 G5 G4 c'est fort en fait
mais en fait je sais pas bizarrement
genre de position ça me fait penser à la
partie Ding contre Maxime au candidat de
4h
ok c'était pas ça du tout la partie mais
il y avait un truc d'espace comme ça
tu peux pas avancer
mais du coup je me demande enfin ok
parce que à un moment je vais faire
foudre j'ai envie de te changer pour
faire
la question
bon je trouve ça plus humain quoi
j'ai du mal à capter la plus-value
j'ai peur quoi si tu fais ça ça va
ouvrir et tu vas perdre ses 5 et
je crois que les Noirs faut juste se
contenter de faire nul si on peut et
basta quoi il a l'air William serein
par rapport à la position
moi je suis un peu quand même avec les
Noirs là
ouais c'est vrai qu'il a l'air plus
confiant que que sa position
[Musique]
que Ding peut espérer l'emporter ah
ouais là si un joueur qui gagne c'est
Ding après bon gaffe peut toujours
arriver mais sur un jeu normal c'est que
les blancs on va partir du principe que
oui on excluant la gaffe et que bon
après nul reste probablement plus il y a
plus de chance plus logique mais bon
il y a plus de nuls mais il y a pas mal
de gains normal en fait si l'autre t'as
pas bougé le fou
c'est normal de jouer tour à eux parce
que l'ordi là il dit fouger 6 meilleur
coup mais bon tu vas le faire un moment
parce que quoi d'autre mais oui mais
tu vas pas lui enlever le pain de la
bouche
[Musique]
après c'est quand même dommage mais si
il a pas fait avant c'est qu'il
considère qu'il doit échanger des fous
donc c'est logique de pas
et peut-être que tu peux te barrer aussi
avec le roi avec les noirs
sont très heureux sur Twitter de la
position des blancs rossan il dit oui on
contrôle total la position pour les
blancs
ok mais il veut vraiment s'activer vers
des 4 mais je sais pas alors attends
du coup mais
je sais mais regarde prise tout recap on
va analyser donc il y a pas de G5
c'est assez forcé comme variante
j'aime bien j'ai droit
ok est-ce que je peux pas
[Musique]
et je monte le roi
et puis
est-ce que tu as le temps de tourner
vite c'est 6
mais bon même cavalier EK4 ça et c'est
trois peut-être non
il peut pas donc croiser 7 kg
c'est 6 à 4 enfin
bon si ça se joue c'est juste c'est
peut-être c'est un truc latin que les
blancs peuvent améliorer quand on sait
pas quoi j'ai d'un coup plus tôt de plus
il a fait en H5
ouais ça a l'air bien de jouer ça de la
part de Ding
peut-être qu'il se fait dinguette là ah
il doit pas être bien il y a
ouais après avoir s'il trouve une sorte
de forteresse mais ouais mais ça a l'air
d'être sur la limite
non non mais c'est bon ok clairement
enfin de toute façon nous on prendra les
blancs depuis tout à l'heure on est
content mais
faut trouver après mais déjà enfin la
première question que j'avais il a joué
avant d'écrire le coup
peut-être tu as le droit de faire un
demi coup de retard
tu devrais vraiment avoir la position
il y a peut-être eu un coup interdit là
de la part de Yann qui aurait peut-être
joué avant d'écrire Maxime qui dit tu as
le droit ouais mais quand même un coup
maximum
mais ouais je sais pas avec le cahier
des 6 si c'était si facile de percer
en tout cas il est pas loin parce que
ouais qu'il est plus actif mais
peut-être visuellement plus actif mais
pas vraiment enfin
mais il faudrait qu'on ouais qu'on
regarde un peu après si j'ai des
positions comme ça avec le client des 6
et la tour blanche-neu si on passe on
fait à 4 à 5 peut-être qu'il y avait du
4 on échange de cavalier et puis petit à
petit on pousse à l'ail le roi et que
l'autre il bouge pas il est comme un
mais après pareil on est peut-être le
roi noir il pouvait partir à l'eldom
toi tu fais tourner
ça se voit rien je pense mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que c'est soit gagnant pour
les blancs soit nul à chaque fois enfin
genre il y a pas de cas où tu prends un
risque en plus avec les Blancs non mais
là tout d'un coup je suis d'autant plus
confiant pour les principes dame F3 G5
pardon
j'aime bien j'ai 4 en fait j'adore le
coup de l'ordi tu peux pas prendre parce
que on te prend tu repars en dessin
ok bah ça retombe un peu dans le salon
C3 j'ai commencé à taper là je porte
faire F3 pour consolider j'ai même tout
rachat
faut réussir à faire marcher c'est pas
facile mais bon j'ai l'impression d'être
partout sur l'échiquet quand même oui
surtout en fait tu peux juste rien faire
un scénario comme ça ou tu as réussi à
me faire ça la belle affaire enfin tu
vas trouver une tournage 5 et puis
moi
j'aimerais pas avoir genre de potion
en fait mais
ouais mais là on réfléchissant le Dame
des trois maintenant
bon prenons tous les coups sont pas mal
la dernière fois j'aime bien
tu prends l'espace et tu commences petit
à petit à
ça peut tellement complètement relancer
le match
ouais bah déjà c'est légalises ça le met
bien dans le match mais en plus il joue
assez vite maintenant regarde un F3
parce que ça peut ressembler à d'une
adale rude comme match aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mais je crois que l'année c'est pas ouf
en plus il est fermé par le même style
que lui en un tout petit peu plus fort
parce que c'était pas beaucoup plus fort
madame en fait ouais mais trop enfin
quelques détails
du troisième enfin alors qu'il est mieux
dans le match mais
de toute attrapé complètement fermé
c'est Verdasco
le jardin
d'Australie la demi-finale
et des fois il a perdu des points tu
sais même pas comment tu les gagnais pas
quoi non mais bon parce qu'il est fermé
je sais pas comment c'était possible
cavalier des quatre ok ok
mais de toute façon c'est un coup je
viens de regarder mais
c'est fini oh si il trouve c'est fini
mais c'est logique mais c'est logique
de qualité mais après on l'évalue bien
ou pas
attention mesdames et messieurs on
reprend des quatre cavaliers B3 c'est
ciao ah c'est complètement fini en fait
il y a plus aucune chance je crois qu'il
l'a vu
ça peut faire mal allez en plus enfin
c'est facile c'est juste pour avoir le
courage de la chaîne call ouais mais
sinon en fait c'est enfin tu termines
parce que tu vas mettre le cavalier en
Cessy tu vas récupérer enfin ouf 5 déjà
attention mesdames et messieurs
non mais mon épouse
[Musique]
allez mon Dingo je sais pas besoin 5
minutes histoire de bien sûr mais il va
le faire mais franchement il aurait été
en blitz ça partait
un peu comme Misha quoi
ça a l'air d'être terminé donc il doit
pas être bien
ah il a pas l'air d'être bien il reprend
même pas tempo oh il est pas bien
regarde et il a même pas repris direct
tu peux penser que tu es assez simple
parce que décès ça doit pas fonctionner
quoi que même des c'est en fait
partie qui fait complètement tourner des
jouets tous les pronostics mais il a
bien gagné enfin
il a explosé façon puzzle
ce qui lui a mis ah il a dézingué quoi
oh regarde il est pas bien oh on
croirait du parano regarde oh le
Paradise paramification mais j'ai du mal
à comprendre ce qu'il a raté bah tu
reprends des catch je pense oui mais tu
attends
la question
non mais ça doit être non mais je pense
juste que c'est horrible à défendre et
tu deviens fou tu vois gs5 enfin et
juste tu perds ta lucidité parce que
c'est dur c'est dur partout mais c'est
pas encore gagné là
non mais je sais mais genre tu dois
avoir G5 enfin
un moment donné du coup ah oui
j'ai cahier des quatre tu sais le truc
qui pique et tu regardes pas ça tu
regardes pendant 10 minutes j'ai 5
machin ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne tu
vois ah dans cette vente tu as
l'impression de souffler de son plus
enfin je sais même pas sur Dame des
trois ce qui comptait faire
oui d'accord mais mais ça va recommencer
quoi
ta position tu tournes tu tournes tu
tournes enfin la saison les a tous fait
hein c'est connerie mon fable
moi le premier moi ça j'ai c'est ce que
je racontais à Baki en plus qu'on parle
une anecdote mardi j'ai une des
dernières parties officielle que j'ai
joué c'était peut-être même la dernière
contre Glenn ok je regarde je réfléchis
sur une position genre 50 minutes
en fait j'ai refusé la ligne 1 2 3 4 et
5 dollars dit parce que j'aimais pas
j'ai joué un coup genre le 7 et ça passe
de moins de 40 ans instant mais j'ai
regardé trois vues oh j'ai ça
c'est j'étais très heureux j'ai joué le
coup je me suis levé finalement
en plus c'était dans l'ordre je refusé
un j'ai refusé deux j'ai refusé trois
j'ai refusé quatre et au bout d'un
moment bah moi je jouais 10 quoi mais ça
ressemble un peu enfin genre c'est des
gaffes classique mais non c'est quand tu
refais quand il y a trop de trucs qui te
plaisent pas tu te mets à jouer un coup
comme ça tu fais encore pire c'est un
peu comme dans Sonic tu sais quand
il a complètement raté
ça va arriver d'être moins bien aux
échecs il faut quand même faire
d'efforts à l'adversaire pour me battre
tu peux pas perdre instant dès que tu es
moins bien quoi qu'il refasse comme le
match précédent il perd ça et bon pour
la prochaine dans une pièce Sandrin il
se fait défoncer
mais
là je sais pas c'est déjà hier je trouve
pas qu'il est fait une bonne partie
n'est pas
bon après je sais pas trop voilà
[Musique]
c'est une sorte de continuité d'hier
c'est incroyable
ouais ça fait penser au match de faire
il l'a fait un closer quoi
il était bien sur sa ligne de foncourt
Ding et coup droit revers il était là
quoi il courait et il a fait
l'essuie-glace à fond à un moment donné
ça a boisé quoi il a boisé en fait mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il a pas eu à faire
de gros efforts
et puis un moment eh peut-être il fait
dame F3 il y a un faux rebond tu vois il
a même pas il a même pas montrer c'est
quoi le plan pour progresser dans la
position c'est ça c'est la balle qui
touche la ligne
ça agit un peu qui ait des 4 il boient
et la BIM quoi il monte à la volée comme
ça et
là il y a encore en train de courir
n'est pas il essaie de mettre une date
quoi ça va être un petit coup de merde
là
mais bon je pense qu'il va se mettre
c'est facile hein
mais en tout cas Ding
même physiquement quoi c'est plus la
même chose
là c'est un combat de sumo mais
avec un avec un poids plume qui frappe
fort
c'est incroyable enfin ça fait plaisir
moi je suis très content ça relance
tellement le match bah pour l'intérieur
du match c'est mieux que je t'oxyde se
passerait qu'il se fait écraser moi je
suis pas spécialement ni pour l'un ni
pour l'autre mais ça
[Musique]
du monde que
c'est pas top quoi
même s'il était cool dans l'intensité
après bon c'était quand même 12 nuls oui
oui en fait ça fait deux enfin ça fait
un match bon serré donc sympa en terme
d'intensité mais
oui il y a pas de victoire donc c'était
un peu un peu relou pour les spectateurs
et un autre où il y a un walk cover j'ai
envie de dire non en plus ouais
il veut juste il attendait les
départages parce que parce qu'il est
beaucoup plus fort
qui espère qu'il se passe un truc mais
puis les départages même si c'est sympa
c'était vite pris c'était oui c'est
comme si tu as intérêt à côté Nice mais
que ça fait 7 ans quoi
normalement ça c'est le climax
la première partie du match Carlson
Caravana elle était réellement
catastrophique de la part des deux
d'ailleurs en fait Carson est très bien
joué genre 40 coups jusqu'à gagnant
après c'est dur de jouer avec le recul
parce que les deux avaient enfin en tout
cas voilà
avant les autres donc il semblait jouer
nettement mieux que tout le monde mais
parce qu'ils avaient accès à une
technologie que personne n'avait avant
mais
après
des occasions ratées quoi la chaise de
carvana
mais je pense globalement ça joue très
bien
non mais en plus c'est des balles
parties quand même enfin la partie
d'aujourd'hui elle est sympa
mais ouais mais oui non mais il est bien
puis à bonne conception de Ding ça c'est
cool mais je sais pas je trouve vraiment
qu'il a perdu trop facilement des fois
dans lequel on dit sauf ça parce que
c'est non seulement c'est plus 4 d'après
l'ordi mais c'est dans le monde
en fait c'est juste une place tu prends
des cas tu vois la tour tu bouffes F4
enfin et tu avances après mais c'est le
grand terrasse enfin
si les colossoparts
il a cassé le mur il a cassé le mur et
les Colosso partent
et là il nage là mais franchement oui
mais bon je me répète mais c'est pas
normal de perdre si facilement
en 5 heures ok tu luttes et puis Ding
joue bien il manœuvre bien il trouve une
faille il trouve un truc et puis OK
bravo
d'exploration bon maintenant les
explorer rien du tout
on vient quoi
j'ai 5 ok bon bah il veut sauver
[Musique]
MG6 et probablement
ok on va voir
on va voir comment il avance maintenant
le plus logique CG4 pour qu'il est F5
oui oui
mais ok bon faut qu'il trouve encore
c'est G4 c'est pas non plus introuvable
mais il y a pas que je pense non mais
juste je pense que j'ai quatre c'est bah
tu vois c'est plus 6
mais c'est trop logique tu vas faire
cavalier F5 au prochain après tu peux
aussi faire cavalier
mais du coup peut-être tourger ça tu
sauve un peu
il va essayer d'un médecin des trucs
enfin j'ai quatre c'est vraiment pas sûr
que tu essaie grand-chose mais j'ai
quatre tu fermes quoi c'est fort ouais
en plus je crois que tu parles tu bois
vraiment le calice jusqu'à la lit tu te
fais lead parce que tu as même pas ça
donc tu as même pas le temps de créer
une illusion d'un truc
ah elle est belle la position c'est une
belle position
non mais pour le coup pour illustrer les
Stripes de qualité c'est une partie qui
sera dans les livres parce que bon on
l'envoie la l'impact des tours en fait
les deux tournois palmarès on est là
quoi puis on a un truc au dessus de la
tête alors que le cavalier il rayonne la
Tour Blanche bah elle est déjà beaucoup
plus forte que les deux autres réunis
ils ont plus de gaz dans leur truc là
pour
l'instant
il va la voir c'est pas trop dur
bon ça retourne non mais le problème
c'est qu'en plus je crois que même si tu
joues
un coupon mais je sais pas combien
l'évaluation mais tu es toujours
beaucoup mieux quoi tu as plus de vin
quoi
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais en fait on reste gagnant même après
la fin juin ouais c'est fou c'est trop
OK
Gaillarde quoi
je te rentre dans le bide
mais en fait c'est un peu comme c'est
dans les jeux vidéo c'est les boss c'est
l'humain peut-être un boss qui a un gros
bide qui arrive qui essaie de marcher
dessus
comme ça quoi
peut-être du coup tu repars toi et tu
sautes un peu de côté et tu attends qui
c'est généralement ils font un truc quoi
il t'envoie des boules de feu tu te
dégages
assez vite
donc on ne coûte 32 mais je suis sûr que
la partie il va reprendre du temps mais
des fois je crois que la seule saoule de
jouer ça non mais là
il fait toujours le même truc en fait
bah de toute façon il a rien à faire je
le reproche même pas de faire non mais
je crois que dès qu'il est mal il te
joue tempo
bon faudra encore avancer après
on va y arriver mais
tu as quelques
éléments perturbateurs
encore réussir à les éliminer quoi
mais je pense qu'on va y arriver quand
même
ouais ouais ouais
on t'envoie un colossal en E7 et puis
aussi c'est en dessin
de partout quoi
ça ressemble vraiment enfin là ça
ressemble vraiment en fait
barre-toi où tu peux quoi une fois sur
la montagne quoi
de la qualité bah il aimerait bien déjà
parce qu'il s'en fout de prendre je
pense Ding mais quand bien même en fait
il y a une telle différence d'espace que
arrêtez de protéger le roi frites
[Rires]
non mais sûrement que
A4 pour faire le même truc pour les
casser et en plus tu donnes des cases
pour passer là-bas après ouais
fin ou ranger
comment ça bouffer des trucs
[Musique]
en fait en terme de d'activité des
pièces
qui protège tu bouffe tu bouffes et tu
pousses et tu pousses
il y a toujours un petit temps qui part
en fait au pire ce sera ce temps-là mais
tu auras toujours un Titanic
quoi
une grosse mâchoire
[Musique]
je suis très heureux
c'est que même si tu fais ça ça ça il va
pas se passer grand chose voilà tu vas
peut-être laisser G4 que tu as pas envie
bah on n'a pas envie que ça s'ouvre
c'est pour ça qu'on aime bien comme ça
dès qu'il fait une tentative d'ouverture
on ferme et du coup il y a pas de
colonnes qui s'ouvre pour les tours donc
il va se passer et là même si tu fais ça
je pense que il va pas t'arriver grand
chose
et après tu fais des trucs tu fais ça
ah tu rentres à 6
j'aurais peut-être perdu mais j'aurais
été très heureux
c'est tellement une position tu as
tellement envie de la jouer cette
position avec les Blancs
oui ça me rendait tellement heureux
d'être avec les blancs
avec les Nord
tu sais que tu as perdu tu as pas une
once de contre jeux
ça m'énerve en fait t'as pas envie
d'abandonner parce que tu as plus de
matériel mais oui donc t'abandonne pas
pourquoi alors dit galère cette position
je crois qu'il galère pas du tout il
donne plus 750
mais bon
c'est terrible à ce qu'il arrive à Yann
le match commençait tellement bien
ouais mais vraiment hier c'était pas
bien quoi
en fait on s'attendait à ce qu'il
cherche à mettre la tête sous l'eau et
c'était pas ce qu'on attendait et là ça
suit ce
nouveau scénario
en fait il est il dominé quoi
[Musique]
grosse grosse victoire
c'est marrant finalement les deux
premières parties les mal payés
ouais bon après hier il m'avait pas de
perdre spécialement mais genre c'est
avec les Blancs
au début j'étais tellement au dessus tu
dis oui
les conférences de presse ou Ding tu as
l'impression que proche de qui il est
tout fait par l'enjeu écrasé par un jeu
on va dire et
[Musique]
ils sont pions dans la main
OK
une certaine dextérité pour faire
tourner le je crois que c'est le
cavalier comme un fou quoi
il y a plus grand chose à dire sur la
partie là c'est
ouais mais non faut attendre la sanction
qu'on va dire
qui peut arriver d'un moment à l'autre
mais après je pense que Yann il est
parti pour la jouer encore un moment bon
oui de toute façon comme tu disais il a
un avantage matériel donc tu as pas
envie d'abandonner au cas où la dernière
se plante
mais tu as tellement rien à jouer
je suis d'accord la question là c'est
combien c'est plus combien de temps
avant l'abandon
ça semble inexorable mais après la
partie elle peut durer même une heure
encore ouais bah c'est le temps en fait
que disons Ding gagne au moins un pion
et qu'on s'est avancer quoi là
tu sais même pas pourquoi il y a une
dernière saison en fait non mais
c'est inexorable
enfin
tu regardes quand même quoi tu es là tu
m'as surtout on veut vraiment voir
comment il marche quoi
mais pourquoi tu te caches en fait
il faut faire
très content de ce coup
là il est désespéré
moi j'aime bien ton A4 quand même pour
aller oui
bah je pense ça fait partie du plan quoi
à un moment une fois qu'on aura bien
assis la domination et c'est le cas on
va ouvrir le deuxième front de l'autre
côté quoi
ce qui est une telle différence de
mobilité entre les pièces
qui bouffe les cases des pièces
on va te faire c'est 5 tu nous laisses
passer en fait tes D6
en fait c'est la seule raison pour
laquelle tu as pas encore abandonné
encore c'est parce que c'est pion
tiennent
dès qu'il y en a un qui est plus là ça
avance
[Musique]
il cherche pas à financer
non
mais toujours attendu pour recette mais
bon
ça a l'air très bien ce qu'il nous fait
ok parce que ça fait une fourchette mais
bon ça à mon avis
ça dure pas très longtemps non non
comme ça par exemple
donc j'ai 8
n'était pas en zoom là
tu te reprends la même fourchette
mais ton rêve 7 dame aussi
[Musique]
ok ça ça peut être un piège
ok mais il va
réfléchis
égale donc il y a un piège quand même
donc ton G7 il faut faire dame
descartres
mais bon il y a un piège encore
oui tu vas faire dame Descartes
ça ça doit être le plus simple
on va pas digne sur la cam ce qui n'est
pas là
du parti se reposer il souffle
il souffling
un quart d'heure pour jouer quatre coups
et après il aura encore une heure donc
il peut bien souffler et reprendre ses
esprits et finir proprement non mais là
il va rien rater Fab je pense pas mais
tu vois
il peut pas là c'est un ratable
il me demande si un champion du monde
chinois donc jamais en fait ça serait
une première
il y a eu chez les filles il y a même
chez les filles il y a toujours
grave elles sont au final des candidates
et la championne est c'est pas c'est pas
parti pour changer parce que la
prochaine champion du monde sera de
nouveau chinoise
et la numéro 1 mondiale est chinoise
mais elle joue plus quasi
en ce moment d'ailleurs
j'ai pas forcément la règle mais je
crois que j'ai vu un truc en ce sens
mais c'est bon en fait c'est que si Ding
gagne tu auras Shin chin chin chin chin
chin
c'est beau mesdames et messieurs
est-ce que tu penses est-ce que si Ding
gagne j'achète un drapeau chinois
ouais on peut le bazar
pour mettre derrière quoi non qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez c'est un petit
drapeau chinois quelques jours quand on
hommage
bon là
il va gagner ouais mais c'est en hommage
quoi enfin c'est beau quoi
les gens disent non
du monde c'est beau quand même
de toute façon
[Musique]
dans tous
ces matchs ou truc individuel
je m'en fous un peu de leur pays quoi
c'est le joueur qui te représente
lui-même
et massif
oui
des échecs
ça arrive pas souvent
ouais qui va gagner voilà magnifique
quand même cette victoire de Digne il
peut faire ce qu'il veut il est pas
obligé de faire des six mais c'est
vraiment fort
c'est vraiment fort le pion bah menace
d'avancer et en cas de prise qui va les
prendre ça fait la fourchette etc
mais oui même si tu passes ton tour de
toute façon les enfants rien
en tout cas c'est bon
c'est belle performance
c'est une table de ping-pong
ils sont hyper fort au ping-pong
mais oui enfin traditionnellement j'ai
l'impression qu'ils sont forts
et au bad peut-être aussi
je sais pas
[Musique]
à la plongée synchronisée là ils sont
hyper fort
je crois qu'ils sont forts dans beaucoup
de sport en réalité mais ils sont pas
forcément forts dans nos sports
principaux le foot vraiment mauvais
parce que ils ont ils ont aussi un gars
super fort
mais bon ça fait une équipe non plus en
gymnastique ils sont forts
rugby sont mal je pense même basket on
est bon
pétanque
après je veux dire
nous voler aussi on est bon bah nous on
se porte quoi on est là
et pas que mais vraiment fort quoi
Formule 1 ouais en fait c'est vrai que
voilà on doit pas être du tout bon dans
les mêmes choses
façon tu vois aux Jeux Olympiques ils
ont plein de médailles d'or
dans tout un tas de sport qui nous
intéressent pas
non mais vraiment ils sont toujours au
coude à coude avec les Américains non
Jeux olympiques d'été ouais je sais pas
trop enfin je crois qu'ils sont toujours
un et deux je sais pas j'ai pas les
rêves parce que ça m'intéresse pas
spécialement mais en plus voilà la
dernière fois les organisons
même devant ouais c'est ça ils sont
enfin ouais ils sont coup d'à côté
ils prennent rien non je dis vert
enfin je regarde je sais plus trop
expert des JO c'est surtout la Norvège
non les pays les pays scandinaves je
crois qu'ils sont super bons
artistique peut-être ils sont là j'en
sais rien ils doivent être là ils
doivent être là de ouf
en eSport ils sont forts aussi ouais
[Musique]
c'est pris tempo
8 ça va abandonner en tout cas bravo
Ding
en plus ça va pas duré très longtemps du
coup
bon on arrive au 41
[Musique]
et la dame aussi dame aussi ça a l'air
de bien bien tuer non mais c'est trop
les sept pour tourner
tellement rien de jouer
7 tours
pour te décaler te faire tourner vite
forcées par exemple
[Musique]
ça devrait pas faire très longtemps
G7 pour D8 dame
en file
mais mon tour est fin tu force ton H6 et
là tu te barres et là tu fais tourner
et là tu forces la bande moi
et tu perdes mais pas que d'ailleurs je
suis de prendre
tu peux même pas espérer défendre
tu as vraiment pas quoi
non non là tu te fais marcher dessus
écrasez ah c'est sympa là ça va faire
deux deux oh j'ai quasiment envie de
changer le score du match je le fais si
tu veux ah c'est risqué est-ce que je
attends
c'est très très risqué ce que je viens
de faire et je vais tweet
attention
tu aurais fait jouer
le tweet qui part
quelle victoire de Ding aujourd'hui le
match est lancé c'est tweeté vous
l'aurez lui ici en premier premier sur
les tweets quand même je suis devant
tout le monde
et c'est bon en fait de tout est juste
avant la formater le premier à tweet
tous les gens peuvent te like bon let's
go mettre un lien vers le tweet premier
sur l'info premier sur l'info vous
l'aurez lui ici en premier
j'ai peut-être ouais je suis un peu
voilà je suis là en fait
[Musique]
je suis un peu quand même
c'est pas fini
ah c'est beau
j'ai pris un risque quand même oh le
ging c'est en place là c'est trop
bien c'était abondant en fait terrible
7 dame prend F5 tout F6
[Musique]
c'est plus qu'une bonne gueule
c'est pas encore abandon direct
[Musique]
après c'est beau pour moi parce que ça
veut dire que mon tweet il va prendre de
l'ampleur et en plus les gens sur le
live vont vont like à mort et vont
retweet
des réponses il va y avoir des réponses
et du coup en fait je vais je vais être
nettement en avant sur tous les autres
tu vois même Gotham va le faire après
quoi
j'ai tout avant toi je ne l'ai pas plus
vite en fait on pourrait chute les
analyses de Gotham ont juste en disant
la partie
avant toi
ce sera pas moins qualitatif après
la vidéo
Chester la mode
[Musique]
je crois que c'est plutôt fortement
là j'ai peut-être une cinq quand même
au pire ça se verra de leçon
on se dira bon interdit quoi
ça fait longtemps donc le même pays
aurait pas eu homme et femme
[Musique]
la dernière fois ça va être l'Union
soviétique après l'union soviétique il y
a bien eu des Russes
[Musique]
à cette période là les championnats du
monde féminin c'était moins cycle en
fait il y a une passe une passade un peu
bizarre
enfin tu vois non mais je sais pas trop
en fait va pouvoir regarder on regarde
tout mais j'ai pas en tête
donc ça va être toi F6 obligé d'amash7 a
priori
et il va monter le roi et ça va être un
peu la rentrée
je trouve que c'était hyper humain
un peu montrer mais genre si tu fais ça
ça ça ça
fait une template
donc du coup il aura jamais genre de
truc quoi pour pour attaquer le pion qui
va rester en recette qui va pacifier la
dame mais pendant ce temps les blancs
vont pouvoir aller cueillir un peu les
trucs à droite à gauche
en fait Ding il a compris ma technique
du tweet en avance récupérer les likes
et tout et du coup il gagne pas trop
vite pour vraiment me laisser premier
sur l'actu quoi c'est très très bien
joué de la part de Ding
il me fait une petite passe des quoi en
quelque sorte merci frérot
ok oui je vais aller liker
non mais là j'ai pas pris beaucoup de
beaucoup de risques
là j'ai pas pris un énorme risque ça
c'est
c'est impossible
ça mérite 1000 likes non
je sais pas moi comme ça
je te dis tout de suite
c'est vraiment semblant d'avoir du mal à
la gagner enfin c'est beau ce qui fait
ah non c'est bien joué
c'est même très bien joué
c'est même excellent bien joué
de toute façon ce sera quasi toujours le
même rythme de partir repos de partir au
repos de partir repos et puis après une
partie repos et repartit au repos à fond
et peut-être pour la dernière il te
refont un truc bizarre non
on leur dit il fait juste la stratégie
de Murtas quoi
de plomber dans une pression gagnante
pour que n'importe
qui fait ça
que c'est vraiment très facile à gagner
en fait
ouais bah c'est ce qu'on regardait
c'était bien c'était une bonne une bonne
ligne
en vrai je pense qu'il doit regarder ça
en fait
c'est bien aussi ça fait plaisir
[Musique]
à cause de tournoi et tu menaces
fait partie le roi de la défense de la
tour
il va faire quoi je suppose
plus de coup tu prends et à Tourer et tu
vas en E5
bonnes
F7 dans l'âge 5
bons noms là en fait ouais
manière de terminer
très jolie manière de terminer
ouais ça sent l'abandon ici
pour Yann
les petits coups
G6 attends j'ai 6 ans
la meilleure défense pour Yann
fuite de torgée 8 pour D8
c'est le plus c'est une sorte d'enfilade
quoi c'est le plus safe
ça devrait finir comme ça
gagne à dos dans la partie ici
mais c'est beau quand il réfléchit à
fond quand même
ouais je vais dans une minute je pense
il va pas forcément déjà trouvé non
bah disons peut-être oui enfin a priori
quand avant de faire dame j'ai ça tu
l'as déjà vu qu'il gagne il se reverifie
bien comme il faut il sort de vraiment
être bien sûr
en tout cas il a une heure
donc bon
combien de temps par rapport au moment
où il était gagnant ça a pris quand on
était vraiment sûr c'était il y a quand
même 12 minutes déjà on a vraiment été
sûr à 100% que ça allait gagner
il aura fallu 14 minutes
pour terminer et c'est une égalisation
de Ding Viren qui revient à deux partout
dans ce match Fab il ne reste plus que
10 parties et oui pour des partager les
deux hommes mais le suspense c'est
complètement relancé et Yann qui va
peut-être voir les démons
de son match contre Carlsen se réveiller
bah là la prochaine série de deux
parties mettre importantes pour voir si
la remettre la pression avec les blancs
ou quoi et puis bah avec les nargues
il y aura des trucs à
corriger parce que là aujourd'hui ça
part en été ça
et ok bah c'est cool pour le match en
tout cas bravo à Ding qui qui relance ça
aurait pu vraiment mal se passer on
rappelle les deux premières ça allait
pas du tout et là ok il y a match même
là il domine tout d'un coup donc ça lui
permet de revenir et ok donc demain
pause ça permet de remettre les idées en
place côté ou de psychoter enfin sur
Paris mais ouais et donc assez important
parce que comme les deux hommes ont
gagné on sait que les deux sont capables
de le faire donc même si un des deux
joueurs gagne ouais mais je veux dire si
la prochaine série gagnant encore tu as
l'impression que Néo ça va commencer à
tilter complètement l'inverse du couding
il peut se relever peut-être enfin ouais
donc on sait pas en tout cas merci à
tous et on se retrouve
rien que pour une petite performance
open sway